Almost heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're ones moved on, under Twitch chat, from those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes, long ago, made you feel, you're not a punk champ, keep a forehead, bible thumb.
Twitch emotes, typing Dan's games, forehead swift rage, PJ salt and fail fish.
Easy, spamming all the time, TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine.
Twitch emotes, long ago, made you feel, you're not a punk champ, keep a forehead, bible thumb.
Twitch emotes, still hear his bark.
In the morning hour he calls me, his doggy emote reminds me of a time far away.
Looking at a chat I get a feeling that I miss emotes from yesterday, yesterday.
Twitch emotes, long ago, made you feel, punk is punk champ.
It's cap is cap bug, Twitch emotes.
Twitch emotes, bible thumb, twitch emotes.
Yo, da bin ich, am Start.
Wow, was ist jetzt los?
Das ist ein neues Feature hier, guckt mal.
Manchmal geht's und manchmal nicht.
Dass sich das minimiert.
Manchmal geht's und manchmal nicht, sehr merkwürdig.
Es geht eher, es geht eher, es geht eher nicht.
Es geht eher, es geht eher, es geht eher.
Es geht eher, es geht eher.
öfters nicht, als dass es geht. Den haben wir dann hier schon am Start. Die Lemurharfe,
exzellent. Der Netto-Asianik ist am Start. Wolle, Doobie Dye, der Easykiller, der Tainser ist da.
Vivo Still, stehst du immer um die Uhrzeit auf? Ne, bin schon ein bisschen wach. Na,
Sana PC lustig, das Ratchet. Und der Hainopa subscribt, exzellent. Oh,
bisschen groß vielleicht, das Emote. Minimal zu groß. Für neun Monate, huge IQ, boost.
So, Jelly ist auch am Start. Ne, also ich bin, wann bin ich hier aufgestanden? Also
ungefähr kurz vor neun, so 8 Uhr 45 oder so. Irgendwie so in dem Dreh. Was empfiehlt uns,
also ich hab schon ein paar Video, oh hier, die Lego Burger Factory, die müssen wir uns gleich
angucken. Aber mal gucken, was uns YouTube
empfiehlt. Ich hab jetzt gar nicht geguckt, was uns YouTube empfiehlt. Jetzt müssen wir
erstmal ne Runde Musik anmachen. Was, was nehmen wir da hier? Irgendwie, ähm, das da,
keine Ahnung. Irgendwas, vollkommen egal. Gucken eh hauptsächlich irgendwelche Videos,
da ist Musik jetzt nicht so. Hallo? Okay. Ähm, Battlefield 4, Battlefield 4 Video haben wir
schon. C++ 20, MonkaS. Ach ne, das ist ein Tutorial für, für Unreal, ne, oder für was
auch immer. Ne, für irgendwas selbst gebasteltes. Okay, das ist C++ 20, MonkaS. Ach ne, das ist ein
C++... Zum Glück kein C++ Tutorial. Seitdem ich gleich hier, hätte ich gleich sagen
muss, not not interested. Oh, Making Indie Games changed my life.
Emo... Es gibt keine Emos mehr, die sind alle weg. Kennst du Minish Cap? Ja, klar, kenn ich.
Habe ich sogar gespielt. Und sogar bis, bis zum Schluss, also durchgespielt. Magi im Check.
Warum YouTube, warum empfiehlst du mir Magi...
Family...
...Familie...
Magi im Check.
Ich weiß nicht, warum sich YouTube jetzt gedacht hat, Magi im Check, das musst du angucken.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein YouTube-Algorithmus-Ding, dass sie ein sieben Jahre altes Video mal wieder promoten.
Das müssen wir nachgucken.
Ja, vor neun Stunden.
Das wird gerade wieder empfohlen.
Developer reagiert auf Speedrun Half-Life 2.
Okay, haben wir das nicht schon geguckt?
Und war das nicht ein bisschen Resident Sleeper?
War das nicht ziemlich Resident Sleeper?
Oh, das ist viel zu lang.
Das war ziemlich Resident Sleeper, fand ich.
Ich meine, wir haben schon Half-Life 2 Speedrun geguckt, Half-Life Speedrun.
Das ist halt zum größten Teil Out-of-Map geklitscht, gerade in Half-Life 2.
Das fand ich nicht so spannend.
Max, wir wollen doch heute ein 15-Minuten-Video anschauen, hast du gestern gesagt.
Echt? Welches denn?
Self-Made-Eyes, abonniert Twitch Prime.
Bisschen laut hier auf einmal die Musik, ne?
Können sich wieder nicht entscheiden.
Ja, Self-Made-Eyes, sage ich schon für den Sub.
Excellent.
Welches Video wollten wir uns anschauen?
Ach, ich weiß wieder.
Ja, ich habe letztens...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das heute so gut passt, weil das ist jetzt ja halt nichts unbedingt so zum Aufwachen.
Ich habe ja gestern mich ein bisschen zu ausgelassen, dass wir in Deutschland so viel Geld haben oder auch nicht.
Ja, da habe ich gesagt, ich habe letztens ein ziemlich gutes 15, ungefähr circa 15 Minuten langes Video zu dem.
Thema gesehen.
Das können wir uns angucken.
Das ist echt, finde ich, nicht schlecht gemacht, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das Aufwachmaterial ist.
Das war das hier.
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz in meine Playlist gucken, dass ich das finde.
Das war eigentlich ganz gut.
Ziemlich neutral, ja.
Er hat einfach nur gesagt, wie es ist und das fand ich gut.
Gibt es wenig, gibt es wenig, die das machen.
Ja.
Wo ist der Wohlstand für alle geblieben?
Ist das...
Wie ist das?
Äh...
Ja, das da.
Das fand ich war ein echt gutes Video.
Der hat es auf den Punkt gebracht.
Relativ neutral, ja.
Ohne irgendwie rumzuflamen, ohne auch irgendwie groß angreifbar zu sein, weil das ist ja...
Gerade in Deutschland ist es relativ einfach, wenn du ein falsches Wort sagst, bist du gleich mal mindestens Nazi, wenn nicht Schlimmeres, ja.
Bist ja also...
Oder zumindest bist du irgendwie ganz, ganz schlimm und extrem.
Nur weil du irgendwas ein bisschen abseits gesagt hast von dem, was akzeptiert ist.
Und das Umschiftergeschick, der sagt einfach, wie es ist.
Das finde ich eigentlich gerade eigentlich ganz gut gemacht haben.
So.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch für einen Witz?
Lego Burger, please.
Ja, das gucken wir gleich.
Lego Burger ist das Beste.
Gibt es ein Video von dir zur PS5-Hardware und oder Unreal 5?
Ja.
Haben wir uns beide schon angeguckt?
Aber ich muss jetzt erstmal zum Aufwachen, muss ich, gibt nix, gibt nix.
Wir müssen uns die Burger Factory angucken.
Excellent, excellent.
Kennst du Gamebrain auf YouTube?
Nee.
Oder vielleicht schon, aber dein naher Channel sagt mir nix.
Guck mal, sogar mit Tablet-Steuerung.
Alter, hä?
Ich weiß nicht, ob man den Burger wirklich essen will, ist mal fraglich, aber die Technik ist geil.
Hast du das mit der VM und macOS hinbekommen?
Ja.
Das hat funktioniert ganz gut, nachdem wir die Forever-Tools installiert haben in Virtualbox.
Eigentlich merkwürdig, ne?
Aber es hat ganz okay funktioniert, aber es war immer noch zu lahms, um es ordentlich zu benutzen.
Hat nicht so ganz funktioniert.
Wie er das hier anliefert, hä?
Guck mal hier, wie er das reinfährt.
Ich frag mich bei diesen Maschinen, wir haben jetzt ja schon ein paar Videos geguckt in der Richtung.
Funktionieren die nur jetzt einmal fürs Video, weil er die exakt richtig auf Millimeter positioniert hat?
Oder funktioniert das immer?
Da.
Ah, ist eine Mücke. Ich habe es genau gesehen.
Was ist denn das?
Ach, das ist Ketchup und Senf, oder?
Ja.
Was eine Sauerei.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr müsst die Teile danach sauber machen.
Und...
Hat nicht so ganz funktioniert.
Blub.
Hä?
Was jetzt?
Was war denn das jetzt?
Ah, das ist da, wo die Brötchen drauf liegen.
Das wirft er weg.
Jetzt kommt der nächste.
Oh, oh, das fällt runter.
Dann noch besser in Faktorio, ne?
Ich glaube, in Faktorio kann man keine Burger bauen.
Naja.
So, jetzt wird erstmal eine Runde Ketchup draufgesprayt.
Ach, ne.
Doppelten, doppelten Belag.
Okay.
Es ist cool, dass es funktioniert.
Sinnvoll ist es nicht, aber es ist cool, dass es funktioniert.
Ja.
Oh, die...
Die Sauerei.
Als nächstes kommt dann die...
Die Burger-Eating-Factory.
Genau.
Kommt irgendwas, was es ist.
So, auf Jelly.
Die ist...
Das ist ja auch gerade...
Das nächste ist Burger-Eating-Factory.
Danach kommt die Burger-Cleaning-Factory.
Und dann die Burger-Refill-Factory.
Aber es ist schon cool, wie er das gebaut hat.
Es ist schon nice.
Es ist zwar komplett sinnlos, aber es ist nice.
Äh...
Ähm...
TH Assassin sagt...
Der Burger sieht wie so ein Plastik-Burger aus für Commercials.
Naja, eigentlich...
Eigentlich ja nicht, weil in der Werbung sehen die Burger immer besser aus als im Laden.
Äh...
Ähm...
Ich hab's schon im Stream ein paar Mal erzählt, aber für die, die es noch nicht gehört haben,
wusstet ihr, dass McDonald's sogar eine richtige Five-Hat-Erklärung dafür hat,
warum der Burger in der Werbung besser aussieht als im Laden.
Da sind die tatsächlich drauf eingegangen, mal bei einer Frage.
Und McDonald's sagt, der Burger im Laden sieht anders aus als in der Werbung,
weil in der Werbung ist es darauf optimiert, dass der Kunde, oder auf den Vorschaubildern,
dass der Kunde erkennt und dass gut präsentiert wird, was alles im Burger drin ist.
Und wenn du es im Laden kaufst, ist der Burger geschmackoptimiert.
Deswegen sieht das anders aus.
Also die haben sich dazu geäußert.
Ey, der Typ...
Wie viel...
Wie viele Lego-Factories hat der Burger in der Werbung?
Wie viel Lego-Factories hat der eigentlich noch gebaut?
Rücke durch den Bagger an!
Äh, nicht den Bagger, wie komme ich auf Bagger?
Den Traktor.
Ich frage mich, wie lange der braucht für so eine Factory.
Das ist nicht in einem Nachmittag erledigt.
Die Erfahrung macht es natürlich auch aus.
Ich meine, wenn er irgendwelche Getriebe und Sachen, die was befördern, baut,
das ist grundsätzlich wahrscheinlich alles immer gleich.
Aber da bist du schon eine ganze Weile dran beschäftigt, bis du sowas fertig hast.
Exakt, Easy.
So sieht's aus.
Kommt, jetzt.
Das ist ein Fließband, oder?
So ein Beförderungsband.
Highly advanced.
Ja, das Searched, das habe ich auch schon gelesen.
Das teilweise sogar, wenn es Toppings gibt, also in der Werbung,
wenn die irgendwie Werbung machen zu einer Suppe oder so,
und da gibt es irgendwelche Toppings, dass die dann auch mal mit Haarspray fixiert werden und sowas.
Das ist ja geil!
Guck mal den Wasseranmacher.
Das ist Big Brain!
Das ist nice, das gefällt mir.
Wirklich gut gewaschen werden die Dinger nicht, ne?
Guck mal, es wird sogar trocken gepustet!
Ey, das ist ja...
Okay, okay, das ist wirklich Massive Brain, das Ding.
Das Trockenpusten ist ja mal richtig Next Level.
Ich war gespannt, wie er das Ganze schneidet.
Wenn er das schneidet, gibt es halt eine Riesensauerei, was die Lego-Teile auf Dauer nicht mitmachen.
Ich glaube, Lego-Teile und Fruchtsäure auf Dauer verträgt sich nicht.
Was ist das denn jetzt?
Okay, ich vermute mal...
Das drückt jetzt da oben drauf.
Und hier schneidet es durch.
Ja, genau.
Dann geht das doch.
Das sind nämlich keine Lego-Teile hier.
Das ist irgendwas anderes mit Messern dran.
Ich finde, ich weiß nicht, ob es nur mir so geht, ich finde irgendwie diese Kameraeinstellung...
Irgendwie sieht die schmerzhaft aus.
Ich weiß auch nicht genau warum.
Als könnte man spüren, dass der Apfel zerschnitten wird gerade.
Au!
Ich habe keinen Apfelschneider, so advancede Küchenutensilien habe ich nicht.
Wenn ich Äpfel esse, was nicht so oft vorkommt, weil Äpfel, lull, dann schneide ich die mit dem Messer.
Ich weiß, das ist sehr low-brain, aber es ist nicht so advanced wie das hier auf jeden Fall.
Ich schneide gar nicht, das geht auch.
Aber nachdem ich nicht gerne Äpfel esse, dann...
Nee, Apfel einfach.
Abbeißen finde ich eklig.
Ohne, dass ich euch jetzt erklären kann, warum, aber das mag ich nicht.
Da hängt dann so viel Spucke dran und so noch, weil man da reingebissen hat.
Mein alter Chef hat immer seinen Apfel komplett gefuttert.
So in gefühlt vier Bissen, inklusive Kerne, alles.
Der war da auf dem Schreibtisch und nach 30 Sekunden war er komplett weg.
Und das hat er gemacht wie das Normalste von der...
Guckt euch mal die Sau rein.
Das hat er gemacht wie das Normalste von der Welt.
Und ich stand da manchmal so daneben und gucke ihn.
Komisch, also...
Und er meinte so, was denn?
Jetzt wird erstmal nur die Birne zerhäckselt.
Oh, die ist Shep, die ist Shep.
Das wird nix.
Ah, er hat gecheatet, habt ihr das gesehen?
Ja, Hex, guckt es euch an.
Die Birne ist Shep.
Und jetzt, hier ist die Birne Shep.
Und jetzt die Birne Grat.
Exposed.
Da hat er nochmal eine extra Kamera.
Jetzt wird es aber hier übertrieben.
Okay.
Ist das eine Zitrone?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich unbedingt so eine Zitrone haben will auf meiner...
Auf meine so komplette Zitrone.
Ist vielleicht ein bisschen Paintschamp.
Anhand der Steckdosen erkennt man gleich, dass er schon mal nicht aus Deutschland kommt.
Wow.
Was gibt das denn, wenn es fertig ist?
Bonk, heißt es?
Es tropft.
Das ist ja aber nicht...
Nee, ich weiß nicht.
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die muss man nicht essen.
Jetzt kommt noch eine Kartoffel hinterher.
Jetzt muss er noch ein bisschen flexen, was das Ding kann.
So eine Kartoffel auf dem Fruchtteller ist vielleicht jetzt nicht so das Ding, aber es funktioniert.
Oh, jetzt wird ausgewechselt zu was?
Zu Pompfrit Factory.
Modular, ja.
Er hat nicht ganz funktioniert.
Excellent.
Und jetzt?
Ah, Big Brain.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das eigentlich Absicht ist.
Das ist eher so ein Nebenprodukt von der Maschine und es sieht halt cool aus und er hat es einfach so gelassen.
Ups.
Hä?
Oh Mann.
Was es nicht alles gibt.
Ich finde das immer noch geil in diesen Videos.
Da können wir uns echt jede Woche eins von angucken.
Es hat irgendwie was.
Genau, ich wollte mal gucken, was uns YouTube allgemein empfiehlt.
So, juckt mich alles nicht.
Hackermythen.
Oh, das können wir gucken.
Also wir wissen ja, dass Hacker prinzipiell in dunklen Umgebungen arbeiten und einen Hoodie aufhaben.
Und natürlich nicht zu vergessen, grün auf schwarz Schrift verwenden.
Ähm, warum habe ich eigentlich im Chat, warum habe ich eigentlich den unanimierten Hackermythen, warum habe ich nicht den animierten Hackermythen im Chat?
Da, man wird es nie wissen, man wird es nie wissen, ja.
Es ist, hier, YouTube hat jetzt ja diese komplett neue Kategorie hier am Start, ne, seit ein paar Wochen.
Weil ich den ganzen Tag nichts anderes als Corona-News sehen will.
Wie heißt das Hacker-Emo, Hackermythes?
Rank.
Moment, da haben wir doch schon mal was geguckt.
Genau, der Typ, der irgendwie, ähm, bisschen Strom gewinnen wollte aus dem Abwasser von seinem Regengrille.
AI learns to play Tetris.
Ja, soll die AI mal machen.
Macht die auch ohne uns.
Which duct tape brand is the best?
Tesa.
Aber ich glaube, Tesa geht nicht als Duct Tape durch, oder?
Windows XP with all sound reversed.
Okay, warum?
Warum existiert, warum existiert dieses Video?
Wer ist auf die Idee gekommen, hat gedacht, das ist eine gute Idee.
3M habe ich auch ein paar Sachen von, ja.
Warum, warum gibt es das Video?
Ich verstehe die Daseinsberechtigung nicht.
Die N64-Vorstellung von 1996, die ist eine Stunde lang.
Ich verstehe den Sinn des Videos nicht, aber nice, dass es es gibt.
Was macht eigentlich die Games, äh, nicht die GameStar, äh, die Games, äh, kommen dieses Jahr.
Gamescom Opening Night, 27.8.
Okay.
Konsequent, oh, die ist jetzt nur online.
Na dann.
Interessiert wahrscheinlich keinen.
Was, da stand doch Canceled, echt?
Ne.
Ähm.
Also ich, ich predikte jetzt mal was, ja.
Ich glaube, Gamescom Online interessiert keinen.
Weil die Gamescom ist ja nur irgendwie keine Messe, wo es wahnsinnig tolle Neuigkeiten gibt.
Es gibt ab und zu mal was.
Zum Beispiel kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Und das fand ich auch cool, dass ich da dabei sein konnte.
Ähm.
Als die, äh, äh, als wir bei Blizzard eingeladen waren, 2000, äh, ach, keine Ahnung, 2017 oder so.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr, wann das war.
Wo sie, äh, die neue WoW-Erweiterung zum ersten Mal auf der Gamescom vorgestellt haben.
Ich interessiere mich null für WoW, aber es war lustig, mal zu sehen, wie krass drauf Blizzard-Fanboys sind.
Haha, die sind so abgegangen, als hätten die jetzt irgendwie, äh, das Rad neu erfunden.
Vor allem bei einer WoW-Explosion.
Dann kommt gar nichts mehr.
Zumindest auf der Gamescom wird ja eh nicht mal großartig vorgestellt, was relevant wäre.
Zum größten Teil zumindest, paar Sachen vielleicht.
Aber, deswegen ist die Gamescom als, als News-Plattform irgendwie total uninteressant.
Was bleibt ist, dass es für viele halt mal eine Möglichkeit ist, äh, ein Event zu besuchen, was sich eben um ihr, um ihr Hobby dreht.
Und man wieder paar Leute treffen, die sie sonst nicht sehen.
Also, Gamescom ist, glaube ich, für viele mehr so Social Events, äh, wie Shotguns, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh.
Äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh.
social event als gaming messe in deutschland dazu kommt dass die games
kommen mittlerweile zur hälfte irgendwie im influenza fan treffen ist was
wiederum witzig ist weil die games kommen auf der einen seite sagt sie
wollen davon weniger aber ohne können sie ja auch nicht
die wissen nicht so genau was wollen ja und dazu kommt dass die games kommen
offline viel viel zu voll ist mittlerweile und jedes jahr voller wird
also die war schon vor vor vor 55 jahren oder so viel zu voll und jetzt
ist sie jetzt platzt sie quasi ja also ich glaube gamescom online hard of
gaming games online wird wahrscheinlich keinen
interessieren weil ich mir auch vorstellen können sie werden das
komplett verkacken mit dem programm wahrscheinlich musste noch in den ticket
kaufen oder sowas wird mich nicht wundern dass irgendwie in games kommt
ticket kaufen oder sowas wird mich nicht wundern dass irgendwie gamescom
geht brauchst das besuchten kannst die wollen ja was verdienen
an oder anscheinend nicht wobei man halt sagen muss sie hätten hier die chance
das gescheit zu produzieren weil sie haben in köln ja auch die esl setzen und
die esl weiß zumindest halbwegs überall so kam es streams macht ja mal gucken
ich glaube ich glaube es wird keinen einen passieren
conk reagiert auf bibis haus nein das interessiert mich überhaupt
nicht was wäre denn jetzt wenn wir auf dieses video reagieren
Das ist dann ein Reaction-Video auf ein Reaction-Video, wo Bibi auf ihr Haus reactet hat.
Das wäre triple, keck-triple-U-Reaction.
The history of Windows 98 development.
Ne, wir müssen es ja nicht übertreiben.
Okay, irgendwie empfiehlt uns YouTube heute keine interessanten Videos.
Da müssen wir irgendwas anderes gucken.
Wir gucken jetzt 10 Hacker-Mythen.
Dann brauchst du aber ReactOS.
Oh, da war wirklich PainsChamp.
Ja, Müller Joe Gamescom ist auch übelst langweilig.
Also, überhaupt ist Gamescom viel zu voll, viel zu laut und viel zu überladen.
Und so, dass du als normaler Besucher, der einfach nur hingeht und sagt,
ah, ich gucke mir mal ein paar Games an, nichts angucken kannst.
Richtig, richtig kacke eigentlich.
Das Einzige, was ich an der Gamescom cool fand, war, dass man mal ein paar Leute gesehen hat,
damals, als ich noch YouTube gemacht habe, so in grauer Vorzeit, die man nur online kannte.
Und dass, wenn man ein paar Termine gemacht hat,
was man muss, ohne Termine, Gamescom ist komplett für den Arsch.
Dass man halt auch mal mit ein paar, naja, mit ein paar Entwicklern konnte man nicht reden.
Außer mit den Entwicklern von ARK, als sie noch neu waren.
Und die waren echt begeistert von ihrem Game.
Meistens sitzt man da ja mit irgendwelchen Marketingleuten zusammen.
Dass man ein bisschen Kontakt mit den Entwicklern, beziehungsweise den Spieleherstellern hat,
ein bisschen Sachen sich angucken kann.
Aber ansonsten ist Gamescom einfach ultra langweilig.
Okay, die 10 Hacker-Mythen.
Ja.
Ich möchte in diesem Video 10 von ihnen aufgreifen und einen kleinen Reality-Check durchführen.
Der erste Mythos, der sich hartnäckig hält, ist, dass ein Black-Hat-Hacker,
also ein Hacker, der illegal hackt, mehr verdient als ein White-Hat-Hacker.
Muss nicht unbedingt sein.
Gerade jetzt, in der heutigen Zeit, wo es so viele Bounty-Programme gibt,
erhört sich ein bisschen Resident-Sleeper an.
Ja, komm, komm Leute, es sind 8 Minuten, die Chance geben wir eben mal jetzt.
In diesem Zusammenhang verdienen.
Nun, meiner Ansicht nach verdient ein Black-Hat-Hacker,
in den meisten Fällen, ein Strafverfolgungsverfahren,
der die Unwissenheit anderer Personen ausnutzt, um sich widerrechtlich an ihnen zu bereichern.
Gemeint ist aber natürlich, was ein Black-Hat-Hacker gegenüber einem White-Hat-Hacker monetär einfahren kann.
Wenn man sich typische Gehälter von Penetrationstestern, die quasi die Gruppe der White-Hat-Hacker repräsentieren,
anschaut, dann sieht man, dass sie jährlich in etwa 60.000 Euro verdienen können.
Top-Verdiener schaffen das sogar auf über 100.000 Euro im Jahr.
Das muss ein Black-Hat-Hacker erstmal schaffen.
Natürlich gibt es vereinzelt Jobs,
die ihn kurzfristig reich machen können,
doch es schwebt ständig das Damoklesschwert der Ermittlungsbehörden über einem.
Wenn man nebenbei noch Bug Bounties erhält,
weil man Sicherheitslücken in Web-Anwendungen von Unternehmen findet,
dann kann man dieses Gehalt zusätzlich durch legale Hacking-Aktionen aufstocken.
Ich bin der festen Überzeugung, dass es nur selten vorkommt,
dass ein Black-Hat-Hacker langfristig mehr verdient als ein White-Hat-Hacker.
Kurzfristig aber schon, wenn man beispielsweise irgendeinen PayPal-Account kapern kann.
Der zweite Mythos befasst sich mehr oder weniger mit der Macht von Hackern.
Dazu habe ich ja auch schon mal gesagt,
ich habe ja auch schon mal in einem Video was gesagt.
Kompletter Schwachsinn.
Hackern wird vor.
Natürlich, man kann, wenn man philosophisch rangeht,
kann man sagen, wenn die Sachen lukrativ genug sind,
dann werden sie irgendwann gehackt oder andersrum gesagt,
wer unendlich Zeit und Energie und Geld und sonst was hat,
wird alles hacken.
Aber das ist ja nicht so, das ist ja unrealistisch.
Können sie nicht.
Totaler Blödsinn.
Könnten sie nicht.
Schwachsinn.
Richtig.
Genau.
absolut big brain subscriber so wie genau so wie du sagst hier
exzellent und wir haben dann noch den thomas cool 110 fünf monate und drei
abonniert abonniert drei monaten folge
IQ steigt heute morgen wieder steil an stonks IQ also gäbe ich ihm recht es ist
kompletter schwachsinn diese diese aussage hacker können alles hacken wenn
ich jetzt mal das ist einfach das simpelste beispiel was mir einfällt ja
wenn ich jetzt irgendwas in den dokument habe wo was was was drinnen steht was
gewährt ist gehackt zu werden ja irgendwie ist das super super secret
was die menschheit gewartet hat ja das steht bei mir in irgendeinem text
dokument und ich lege dieses text dokument auf den usb stick und ziehe den
usb stick ab und lege ihn bei mir hin
dann ist das erst mal nicht hackbar im klassischen sinne doch doch dann ist
das nur im klassischen sinne hackbar nämlich dass einer bei mir einbricht so
also so richtig echt so durch fenster und so ja aber dann ist er nicht hackbar
im eigentlichen sinne weil der usb stick liegt abgezogen irgendwo in der ecke also
man kann nicht alles hacken das ist schwachsinn ja np problem sondern macht
das internet zu einem offenen buch solange diese
probleme nicht gelöst werden kann ein hacker zwar viele angriffs vektoren nutzen
um an sein ziel zu gelangen doch der großteil wird in der praxis
der breach die machen doch genau bei mir wird das doge prete die zeitlupe zu
sich den usb stich man kann sowieso reich wird wenn man das
pnp problem löst dafür muss man das dann nicht für illegale zweck ersetzen man
bekommt schon genug ruhm und anerkennung dafür viele glauben dass es hacker numms
geld geht wenn du dir mein video zu den verschiedenen hüten die sich ein hacker
aufsetzen kann, angesehen hast, dann weißt
du, dass es neben Geld, dann geht es vor.
Nee, gar nicht. Ist es
gar nicht. Die meisten Leute interessieren
sich einfach dafür.
... noch weitere Motivationen, wie etwa
Spaß, Anerkennung oder Neugier gibt.
Der Hacker, der jüngst den Instagram-Account
von Mercedes gekapert hat, war bestimmt
nicht finanziell motiviert, sondern wollte
vielleicht Anerkennung von seinen Idolen oder einfach
nur Aufmerksamkeit. Auch Rache-Gelüste
motiviert viele Hacker dazu, anderen zu schaden.
Zudem kann es politische Beweggründe
dafür geben, sich vor den Bildschirm zu setzen
und in fremde Systeme einzudringen.
Wenn man an Hacken denkt, dann kommen einem sofort
die Bilder von dunklen Gestalten mit Kapuzen
in den Sinn, die als Kriminelle dargestellt werden.
In der Welt des Hackers gibt es natürlich
auch schwarze Schafe, doch im Kern handelt
es sich bei einem Hacker um jemanden,
der einen Gegenstand kreativ zweckentfremdet
und ihm eine neue Bedeutung zuführt.
Populär sind zum Beispiel auch sogenannte
Lifehacks, bei denen man versucht, kreative
Lösungen zu finden. Da gibt es ein paar coole
Worts von
Lifehacks, wo
manche Leute ziemlich überrascht sind,
wie schnell man
irgendwelche
RFID-Chips auf irgendwelche
Karten auslesen kann oder sowas.
Übrigens, noch mal zu dieser
Geschichte, diesem P, P
und NP-Problem.
Wenn ich das aus dem Kopf richtig zusammenkriege noch,
was das gewesen ist,
ich glaube, das ist irgendwas
aus der Mengenlehre, wo es da drum
geht, P ist irgendwie die Menge
aller Probleme, die sich lösen lassen
oder die sich in
sinnvoller Zeit lösen lassen
und NP ist die Menge
der Probleme,
die man quasi
überprüfen kann, ob sie richtig gelöst sind.
Stimmt das? Hat er irgendwie eine Ahnung
von? So, und die Frage
ist, ob diese beiden Mengen gleich
sind oder ungleich.
Also sprich, die Menge der Probleme, die sich
in sinnvoller Zeit lösen
lassen, ob das gleich
oder ungleich der Menge ist,
der Lösung.
Und die man überprüfen kann, ob sie korrekt gelöst
sind. Irgendwie so.
Zu finden. Auch diesen Bereich kann man dem
Hacking zuordnen, wobei man
kaum als illegal bezeichnen würde.
Als Faustregel kannst du dir merken,
wenn du nicht die Erlaubnis besitzt, in ein
System einzudringen, dann ist dein Handeln
illegal. Klingt ziemlich einfach,
ist es auch. Wenn du jedoch die Erlaubnis
eines Unternehmens hast, auf ihrem System
zu schaustellen. Oh, der Big-Brain-Chat-Talk,
jetzt geht's ab, das hätte ich jetzt nicht sagen sollen.
Aber ich bin immer wieder
begeistert, wie viel exzellent High-IQ-Leute
wir im Chat haben. Das liegt nur an
den Subscriber. Ohne Subscriber wäre
das hier angesagt. Mit Subscriber ist das hier angesagt.
Das ist beispielsweise
bei einem autorisierten Penetrationstest
der Fall, dann bewegst du dich rechtlich
auf der sicheren Seite. Nicht alles in der
Welt des Hackens ist illegal. Das stimmt.
Ja klar. Ich darf
auch,
viele tun immer so nach dem Motto, oh nee, das darf
man nicht machen. Zum Beispiel an eigenen
Geräten, wenn ich mir die gekauft habe,
also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel meine
Playstation Vita flashe,
frag ich mich, ob man da mal von Hacken reden kann.
Aber viele Leute würden da wahrscheinlich von Hacken reden.
Ist das nicht illegal? Das darf ich
machen. Das ist überhaupt kein Ding. Ob ich das jetzt
live auf Twitch streamen darf, das
ist glaube ich so eine Grauzone.
Aber was ich definitiv
nicht auf Twitch streamen darf, ist die IHK-Abschlussprüfung.
Weil wir
in Deutschland sind. Und
Abschlussprüfung von einem Ausbildungsberuf
super secret ist und jemand Geld damit verdienen
will.
... nicht verstehen und keine Berührungspunkte
mit dir haben, glauben sie, dass man hochintelligenten
sein muss, um sich in dieser Welt
zurechtzufinden. Dem ist aber nicht so.
Ich vertrete die Ansicht, dass jeder
alles lernen kann, wenn er sich dafür interessiert.
Man muss kein Überflieger sein, um
eine erfolgreiche ... Also jeder alles,
ja, aber ich
frage, wie gut. Ein gewisses Talent
und ein gewisses Brain
gehört bei manchen Sachen schon dazu.
Und das
Wichtigste ist eigentlich,
dass man sich dafür interessiert.
Und ich würde mal
sagen, es kommt oftmals zusammen.
Leute, die sich für logische
Zusammenhänge interessieren oder halt
eben halt auch letztendlich
für sowas hier,
das sind in der
Regel Leute, die zumindest nicht ganz
doof sind.
Das kommt, glaube ich, kommt so ein bisschen das Eins zum Anderen.
Ja, also
sagen wir mal, Chantal
aus dem Arbeitsamt Kurs wird jetzt vielleicht
nicht unbedingt auf die Idee kommen,
ich werde jetzt Hacker.
Tainzer hat mir schon wieder ein Abo
geschenkt hier und zwar
an
Er hat nichts, ja.
Jetzt hefst du wenigstens in vier E-Mails.
Danke schön für das Subgift.
Das ist ein Abo-Häfer,
ist er jetzt.
Subscription-Häfer.
Ja, also genau.
Ich glaube, da kommt oftmals eins zum Anderen.
Also sprich, dass Leute,
die sich dafür interessieren und
dadurch, dass sie sich für dieses Themengebiet interessieren,
eh schon nicht ganz so blöde sind.
Also,
prinzipiell nicht erforderlich,
aber ich glaube, bei den meisten
die sind trotzdem nicht ganz blöd.
Bei Angriffstechniken beherrscht
kommt man in Vorstellungsgesprächen für entsprechende
Stellen schon sehr weit. Das stimmt. Der Schein trügt
also. Zudem gibt es ja auch noch
die Skript-Kiddies, die zwar auch zur Klasse der
Hacker zählen, aber wenig bis gar kein
technisches Know-how mitbringen. Und
wenn man sieht, wie naiv sie teilweise
sind. Das Video ist, ich glaube, simpler könnte
das Video nicht gemacht sein. Black Screen?
Hahaha. Und einfach weißen
Text drauf.
... nicht unbedingt die hellsten Kerzen
auf der Torte sind. Wenn man sich Hackerfilme
wie Who Am I oder Passwort
Swordfish anschaut, dann bekommt man leider ein
völlig falsches Bild vom Hacken vermittelt.
Oder bunte Oberflächen, auf denen in
atemberaubender Geschwindigkeit Codezeilen
von links nach rechts und oben nach unten sausen,
gibt es in der Realität meistens nur
ein paar Konsolenfenster, auf denen
ein normaler Tippgeschwindigkeit verschiedene Befehle
eingetippt werden. Wenn du dir Kali Linux,
das ist eine Linux-Distribution, die
speziell für Pentester entwickelt wurde, herunterlädt,
dann wirst du auch kaum Tools mit
optisch ansprechenden Benutzungskompetenzen
und man bringt mehr konsolenbasierte
Anwendungen. Das ergibt auch Sinn, denn
Anwendungen, die für das Hacken von Systemen
gedacht sind, müssen nicht toll aussehen,
sondern effizient und zuverlässig laufen.
Übrigens, eine gute Serie, die einem
halbwegs realistischen Einblick in die Welt des Hackens
ermöglicht, ist Mr. Robot.
Wo halten sich Hacker in ihrer Freizeit?
Ich mag aber Mr. Robot nicht.
Ich hab schon teilweise gesagt,
Mr. Robot, die erste Hälfte der
ersten Staffel, ist ziemlich gut.
Danach geht's vielmehr darum, dass der
Hauptdarsteller einen Dachschaden hat.
Wo treffen sie sich? Doch bestimmt
im Darknet. Nein,
Hacker treffen sich nicht nur im Darknet,
um neue Angriffstechniken auszutauschen,
sondern auch in normalen Tech-Forum.
Der Informationsaustausch findet sogar hier
auf YouTube statt, wie du beispielsweise an meinem Kanal
siehst. Dieser Mythos hält sich vermutlich
immer noch, da viele glauben, dass Hacken
grundsätzlich illegal ist. Aber du weißt es
ja mittlerweile zum Glück besser. Hacker
treffen sich auch nicht nur online, sondern
auch auf großen Hacker-Events, beim CCC
oder bei anderen IT-Interessierten
zu Hause. Man kann auch mittlerweile seine
Hacking-Fähigkeiten bei sogenannten CTS
unter Beweis stellen.
Das hat doch etwas mit Computern zu tun.
Das finde ich eigentlich ziemlich cool, dass
auf YouTube mittlerweile
sowohl Competitive Programming
als auch Capture-the-Flag-
Security-Sachen
durchaus die ein oder anderen
Viewer erreichen.
Das finde ich richtig nice.
Ich glaube, das hätte
vor fünf Jahren
gab es sowas auf YouTube nicht. Aber mittlerweile
gibt es Channels, die haben tausende Aufrufe
mit Security-CTF-Geschichten,
Competitive Programming
und sonst was. Finde ich
nice, dass es mittlerweile dafür
Abnehmer gibt.
Hacker haben also bestimmt alle Informatik
studiert. Falsch gedacht.
Hacken beschränkt sich nicht nur auf Web-Anwendungen
und Software-Produkte, sondern auch
auf Hardware-Geräte und die menschliche Psyche.
Demnach ist es nicht verwunderlich, dass
Hacker aus den verschiedensten Bereichen kommen.
Bei Stellenbeschreibungen wird zwar immer wieder
das Informatik-Studium genannt, doch auch
Elektrotechniker, Mathematiker,
Physiker und Ingenieure können sich bei entsprechender
Einigung auf solche Stellen bewerten.
Wir haben uns ja gestern mal wieder ein bisschen Spaß an der Freude
ein paar Stellenanzeigen angeguckt.
Das ist eher so ein Richtwert.
Letztendlich ist es denen scheißegal. Wenn du zehn Jahre
Erfahrung in irgendeinem Gebiet hast,
dann werden die außer vielleicht,
es ist irgendwas staatliches,
aber jeder,
der noch halbwegs bei Verstand ist,
wird dann nicht sagen, wie sie kennen,
was zehn Jahre und kennen sich gut aus.
Ah, aber sie haben die falsche Note im Zeugnis stehen
von vor 20 Jahren. Ne, ne, dann können wir sie nicht nehmen.
Das wäre ja komplett
low-brain bescheuert.
Außer es ist irgendeine staatliche Stelle da,
die haben sie ja eh nicht mehr, was das angeht.
Man muss auch nicht immer ein Studium abgeschlossen haben,
um in diesem Bereich tätig werden zu können.
In vielen Fällen reicht auch eine Ausbildung
oder ein Quereinstieg mit vorangegangener
autodidaktischer Weiterqualifizierung.
Autodidaktischer Weiterqualifizierung.
Excellent.
Das ist mal eine schöne Wortkombination.
Die gefällt mir.
Wenn man an einen Hacker denkt, dann assoziiert man
mit der Person, die hinter ihm steht,
häufig fette Nerds mit Brille.
Auch das ist ein Mythos.
Es gibt schließlich nicht nur die rein technischen Hacks,
sondern auch andere Bereiche, wie etwa das Social Engineering.
Da der Mensch die größte Schwachstelle
macht.
Aber es gibt schon einige, die
ziemlich, also es gibt viele, die ziemlich klischee-mäßig aussehen.
So ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Man kann jetzt nicht behaupten,
das wäre das komplette Gegenteil davon.
Nein, das sind nicht alle.
Und auch bei weitem, also es sind auch jetzt nicht
irgendwie 99 Prozent.
Aber viele sehen wirklich schon
ziemlich stereotypisch aus.
Als Umfeld ist, sind Angriffe auf den...
Ich meine, guckt euch mal die
Vorträge beim CCC und sowas an.
Also da sieht man, es sind nicht alle,
klar, aber ein Großteil sieht schon echt...
Ich meine, ich nehme mich ja da jetzt da nicht aus.
Das ist ja nicht so...
Sehen schon echt stereotypisch aus.
Menschen als soziales Wesen
viel, viel versprechender als die Penetration,
Versuche bei Computersystemen.
Wenn man bei einem Social Engineering-Angriff
als sozial isolierter Nerd auftritt,
dann hat man wenig Chancen...
Das stimmt, das stimmt, das richtig.
...gute Social Engineers sind oft Menschen mit einer
charismatischen Ausstrahlung und einer sehr guten
Menschenkenntnis. Doch auch für das Hacken
von Computersystemen muss man kein Nerd sein.
Genauso wie man kein Nerd sein muss, um sein
Informatikstudium erfolgreich abschließen zu können.
Einige glauben, dass Hacken reine
Männersache ist. Doch das stimmt nicht.
Mittlerweile gibt es da einige.
Sie sind zwar wie in fast
allen Tech-Bereichen in der Minderheit,
kann man sich ja natürlich auch die Frage stellen, warum eigentlich,
doch sie sind nicht weniger geeignet.
Oh nein, nein, das Thema sprechen wir jetzt nicht an.
Sonst geht's, sonst geht's wieder los.
Nein, nein, das lassen wir links liegen, das Thema heute.
Im Umfeld des bereits angesprochenen
Social Engineerings können sie aufgrund ihrer
Herangehensweise an Probleme und ihrer Ausstrahlung
wesentlich... Herangehensweise an Probleme.
Erstmal Boobcam einschalten.
Easy. Donation.
...geeignet sein als ihre männlichen Kollegen.
Das geht aber natürlich...
Da hat er recht, da hat er vollkommen recht, ja.
Es gibt auch brillante, technisch versierte Frauen.
Bedenke, dass Ada Lovelace als Frau
die erste Informatikerin...
PC Lustig, wahrscheinlich nicht.
...eine eigene Bezeichnung für einen weiblichen Hacker,
nämlich Hexe. Das deutet bereits
darauf hin, dass es eine nicht zum Verlager
...Ich dachte, Hexe macht Battlefield-Videos.
...weiblichen Hackern gibt.
Vielen Dank fürs Zusehen. Solltest du weitere Fragen haben,
kannst du sie gerne unten in den Kommentaren posten.
Bis zum nächsten Video.
Ja, passt. Nice Video.
Über.
Ich, äh, zwar ein paar Punkte kann man diskutieren,
aber im Großen und Ganzen, ja, würde ich, würde ich, sehe ich, sehe ich genauso.
So, was haben wir als, was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Ein bisschen was nicht so big brainiges.
Some Battle, Battlefield.
Komm, wir gucken eine Runde Battlefield, Leute.
Oder Bauer testet den, die neue Intel-CPU, die, äh, tausend, wo ich tausend Euro für
ausgeben muss, für, äh, ein FPS mehr.
Excellent.
Okay, komm, wir gucken, wir gucken eine Runde Battlefield.
Best Moments.
Der hat sogar Top Plays rausgegeben.
Das ist jetzt der Best von den Besten ist das.
Max, was sagst du zu Python?
Ähm, inwiefern?
Also, was genau willst du wissen?
Ich meine, es ist eine von zigtausend Programmiersprachen.
Eine der bekannteren.
Eine der, der beliebtesten zur Zeit.
Ähm, eine der aktuell auch angesagtesten, gerade was, äh, Machine Learning und solche Geschichten angeht.
Okay.
bin ich persönlich jetzt nicht so der Riesen
Python Fan. Ich kann es lesen,
ich kann es schreiben, aber
ist jetzt nicht das, wenn ich die Auswahl
hätte, was ich nehme, was ich
nehmen würde. Ja, das
ja, jetzt habe ich eigentlich schon
alles gesagt, ja.
Ich bin, ich mag
das mit den Einrückungen nicht, muss ich euch ehrlich
sagen. Es ist nicht, es ist eigentlich das, was
mir, was mich am meisten nervt.
Ich bin einfach, Klammern
Fanboy.
Was das angeht.
Ich mag Klammern um meine Blocks.
Wird eigentlich Pascal
noch benutzt?
Bestimmt irgendwo. Ich meine, Kobol wird auch noch
benutzt.
Würdest du dich eher für Holy See entscheiden?
Holy See ist ja quasi eher so eine
so ein Subset von C.
Keine eigene Sprache, sondern quasi
eher so Guides, wie sollte man C verwenden?
Ich glaube, für C braucht
man keine Guides. Also keine
Einschränkungen
mehr. C
kann schon so wenig. Da kann man
ruhig alles benutzen, was da ist. Und die
Erweiterungen bei C sind auch recht sinnvoll
die letzten Jahre gewesen. Beispielsweise
dieser, dieser Struct Initializer
und sowas. Kannst du dich echt nicht beschweren.
Also man muss sagen, im Vergleich zum C++
Gremium, äh, wird
C mit bedacht und sinnvollen
Sachen weiterentwickelt.
Luku sagt, ich habe eben mit Python angefangen.
Ist eine super Sprache zum Einstieg. Eines der besten
Sprachen, die man zum Einstieg sich angucken kann.
Aber generell, wenn man anfängt
mit Programmieren, sollte man sich, äh, halt
überlegen, was, was will man machen. Also sprich,
wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel Windows
Desktop Anwendung machen will, ist Python
vielleicht nicht die beste Wahl. Ja, oder
ähm, wenn man
irgendeine Webseite machen will, dann ist Python
vielleicht auch jetzt nicht die erste
Wahl, weil man braucht
nach wie vor HTML, CSS und JavaScript
fürs Frontend. Aber im Backend kann man es wunderbar
verwenden. Sie fragen, was man machen will,
ja, aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine super Einstiegsprogrammiersprache.
Was ist deine Lieblingsprogrammiersprache?
Äh,
die Kombination aus .NET Core
und C Sharp gefällt mir
mit Abstand, ohne, äh, wirklich mit riesem
Abstand am besten. Es gibt für mich
nix, was ich, also was ich für mich
so angenehm zu programmieren und
zu entwickeln anfühlt, wie .NET Core
mit C Sharp. Eines der nutzlossten
C-Features ist Generic.
Hab ich noch nie verwendet.
Ähm, ich hab letztens mal einen
Blogpost über Generic gelesen.
Da kannst du irgendwelche Typumwandlungs
Geschichten machen. Ich
krieg's aus dem Kopf nicht mehr zusammen.
Hab ich mir nicht angeguckt. Aber, ich, ich
könnte mir vorstellen, wenn man's mal braucht,
ist es gut, dass es da ist.
Hast du schon Doom Eternal gezockt? Wenn ja,
ich fand's ziemlich gut.
Ziemlich gut. Ja.
Es hat ein bisschen Anlaufschwierigkeiten,
Doom Eternal, finde ich.
Aber, ähm, wenn man mal so
zwei, drei Stunden gespielt hat, wird das richtig gut.
Ja, äh,
LuiQ,
dann ist das für dich exakt die
beste Programmiersprache zum
Anfang, äh, zum Anfang und du kannst es auch länger,
längerfristig verwenden.
So, also gucken wir uns mal
aktuelle Battlefield, Battlefield Plays
an. Wird ja mal, wird ja mal
wieder Zeit.
Excellent. Top.
Top.
Äh, kannst du gute Projekte für Einsteiger empfehlen?
Ich hab letztens auf Github was gesehen,
wo jemand, ähm,
ne Sammlung hatte für
Einsteigerprojekte.
Github
Program...
Vorschläge für Beginnerprojekte
hab ich letztens auf Github gesehen.
For Beginners, Beginnersproject.
Musst du mal suchen.
Projectlist...
Gibt's, gibt's jede Menge Vorschläge.
Ähm, wo's natürlich
ums Üben geht. Jetzt nicht
unbedingt so sehr, dass da was rauskommt, was du
am Endeffekt, äh, groß
verwenden kannst oder, oder vielleicht
sogar verkaufen, aber verkaufen kann man eh
das Wenigste.
Verkaufen kann man nur irgendwelches Business-Zeug, was
die Leute brauchen. Ich überleg gerade,
was ist so das, was ist so das schönste Beginnerprojekt?
Also ich, ich denke, es hängt nicht so
ein bisschen von der Sprache ab, was du machst.
Ja? Ähm...
Was, was ein gutes Beginnerprojekt
ist. Python, Python...
Ja gut, wenn du, wenn, Python
Beginnerprojekt, äh, wo Python ja total
angesagt ist, ist grad im Bereich
AI. Ich weiß nicht, was es da für schöne
Beginnerprojekte gibt. Ähm...
Ich würd, ich würd wirklich mit den
Basics anfangen. Wie man heutzutage
so schön sagt. Die, die Basics,
das ist das Wichtigste.
What the fuck?
Was machen die denn da auf dem Boden, Alter?
Das ist gestellt, oder?
Ist das gestellt?
Ich weiß nicht, das, das
könnte schon ein bisschen Setup sein.
Das könnte
schon ein bisschen Setup sein.
Also so, so dumm, so dumm
und, und...
Aber ist trotzdem lustig
irgendwie.
Nee, das ist gestellt. Das muss
gestellt sein, Alter.
Das, das war schon geil, ey.
Oh, es ruckelt.
Ah, nee, das ist auch mal Zeitlupe.
Oh, blubb.
Vielleicht war es auch doch nicht gestellt.
Aber es, es sah schon irgendwie
sehr gestellt aus.
Bumm. Fall, was hat der für
nen Foff? Was ist denn das für ein Foff?
Foff 250, oder was?
Der fliegt
voll rein. Der fliegt
voll rein.
Erstmal schön
360t.
Der fliegt voll rein, mit dem
Chat. Zieht man der jetzt schon?
Bäm! Nee, doch nicht.
Irgendwas anderes ist reingeflogen.
Der Typ ist immer den gleichen Text vor.
Ja, es ist immer exakt das gleiche, was er erzählt.
Ah, excellent.
Grafikglitches.
Boah.
Cool.
Das war das Beste an Battlefield 3 und 4.
Die Fahrzeugphysik eher.
Kennt ihr noch die fliegenden LAVs und sowas?
Bam.
Excellent.
Der Heli hält auch nichts von normal fliegen, oder?
B-29-Korn, 10 Monate.
Oh, oh, oh, jetzt hier.
Excellent Subscription.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
An der Stelle ist mir mal was passiert.
Das muss ich gerade mal zeigen.
Wie hieß mein...
Ich habe noch mal einen zweiten Channel gemacht auf YouTube,
wo ich hier...
...ab und zu mal ein paar Battlefield-Clips und Zeug gepostet habe vor Jahren.
Da gab es was Cooles.
Ja, das da.
Das ist genau an der gleichen Stelle passiert.
Oder doch nicht?
Nee, er slidet über den Boden.
Er slide einfach nur.
Das war es nicht.
Wo ist das denn?
Das da.
Das da ist es.
Das hier.
Geil, oder?
Keck W.
Guckt es euch mal an.
Dum-de-dum-de-dum-de-dum-de-dum-de-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum-dum.
Oh.
Da erinnere ich mich heute noch dran an dieses Schwachsinnstod.
Einfach voll gegen die Mauer gedüst, warum auch immer.
Äh, wo ist das Battlefield Video?
Ja, bestimmt lag, ja wahrscheinlich.
Aber ich bin einfach geradeaus gelaufen und auf einmal beschleunigt es mich und schlägt
mich gegen die Wand.
Das ist Konsole oder er hat Motion Blur an, eins von beiden.
Das ist typisches Konsolen Motion Blur, ja Playstation.
Zack, oh der Heli kriegt es dick.
Äh, what, er hat den Jet abgeschossen, das war aber, das war einfach nur Glück, ja.
Und, und, und, und, und, und, und, oh, exzellent, das war cool.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß das immer gar nicht so richtig zu würdigen, weil ich halt nix,
kein Jet noch Heli fliege.
Der Road killt jetzt, der Road killt jetzt Leute auf dem Dach.
Ich glaub den Clip haben wir schonmal in abgewandelter Form woanders gesehen.
Die denken sich da drin jetzt auch, what the fuck, Alter.
Auf einmal steht ein Panzer auf dem Dach.
Get rekt.
Nice.
Hm?
Battlefield-Physics! Oh, wenn er den in den Chat trifft...
Wow! Okay, das ist heftig. Es ist halt mega Glück, wenn er den in den Chat trifft.
Es ist mega Glück, aber trotzdem übelst krass.
So ein Schwachsinn ging echt nur in Battlefield 3 und 4.
Der Roadkill eben auch. Der Roadkill-Typ, der hat sich auch gedacht, Moment, das kann
jetzt nicht echt passiert sein, oder?
Oh, oh, oh.
Auf dem Dach in Bloodzone.
Ich meine, man darf jetzt nicht davon ausgehen, dass das reproduzierbar geht, ne?
Also, die haben das wahrscheinlich 200 Games probiert und das sind alle Clips, die sie
rausgekriegt haben davon.
Der Panzer bringt dir hier oben drauf überhaupt nichts, weil du nicht nach unten schießen
kannst. Es ist komplett sinnlos den Panzer auf dem Dach zu haben.
know that I play so good.
Ja, stimmt. Das ist cool.
An A-A-M.
Okay, das ist auf gut Glück.
Das ist halb prediktet, aber auf gut Glück, dass er da reinfliegt.
Bam!
Das ist ein richtig geiles Gefühl, wenn man solche Shots trifft.
Richtig Poggers.
Das war auch wieder ein Satz, oder?
Den hätte außerhalb von Twitch keiner verstanden.
Das ist ein richtig geiles Gefühl, richtig Poggers.
Firestorm.
Und...
Platsch.
Bam!
Der Heli fliegt auch nur geradeaus im Sparbetrieb.
Zack.
Den Clip haben wir auch schon gesehen, oder?
Die stehen das ganze...
Damn, auf dem Strommast oder was das ist und schießen geradeaus.
Das könnte sein, aber es gab so Momente auch wirklich.
Es könnte sein, dass die absichtlich reinfliegen, aber es gibt Momente, da passiert das wirklich.
Also, denen würde ich jetzt mal nichts unterstellen.
Dem am Anfang mit dem Motorrad, das sah sehr nach Setup aus.
Ja, so Momente, das gibt es schon.
Da T-Bag der erstmal eine Runde.
Wir müssen an der Stelle nochmal kurz sagen, wie geil Parasail Storm aussah als Map.
Vom Wetter her.
Leider finde ich, hat sich Parasail Storm gerade in Rush grottenschlecht gespielt.
Aber optisch mit den Wellen, die Map sah wirklich cool aus.
Ist das nicht auch die Map mit dem Hai?
Ist hier nicht auch der Hai irgendwo gewesen?
Was ist das für eine Grafik?
Ist das Xbox?
360 oder was?
Die Musik im Hintergrund.
Schau wieder.
Die hatten wir doch jetzt gerade.
Wie oft wollen sie das jetzt noch machen?
Also, langsam werden die Shots auch ein bisschen Resident Sleeper.
Ich meine, die machen das ganze Game nichts anders, als den Heli in ihre Rakete fliegen lassen.
Ähm, das ist eine gute Frage.
Der echte Proxy sagt, meinst du, dass Battlefield bald zu alter Form kommen wird?
Gott, schafft es ja leider nicht.
Nö.
Ich glaube, die haben keine Ahnung mehr, was sie machen.
Und die Leute, die es wissen, sind nicht mehr da.
Battlefield 5 haben sie nachgebaut.
Okay, wusste ich gar nicht.
Wow, der war cool.
Schon wieder die Typen auf dem Strommast.
Die machen echt den ganzen Tag nichts anderes.
Was macht...
Das glaube ich dem nicht.
Ey, das muss doch so was, muss doch Setup sein.
Was macht denn der Heli da oben?
Warum steht der einfach nur da und bewegt sich nicht?
Oh, die Map.
Ähm...
Was für eine Map war das nochmal?
Silkroad oder so, ne?
Oder wie hieß das Ding, die Map?
Die hat man nicht oft gespielt.
TV-Rakete.
Aber so lang?
Okay, das war cool.
Moment, das muss ich mir gerade nochmal angucken.
Also nicht das.
Das andere, das hier.
Übrigens, der hat schöne Color Correction für die Map.
What?
Wie hat er den denn getroffen?
Hä?
Ähm.
Sack.
Die Musik, also.
Aber ich muss euch sagen, das geilste Gefühl in Battlefield war, in Bad Company 2 mit dem AT-4 einen vollbeladenen Heli abzuschießen.
Das war das Beste.
Und das ging in Battlefield Bad Company 2 auch ziemlich gut, weil die Helis fett waren und langsam.
So einen vollbeladenen Heli mit dem AT-4 in Bad Company 2 rausgelasert.
Das war das Geilste.
Okay, ich muss euch sagen, wir haben genug AT-4-Shots.
Das reicht.
Jetzt, ich will mal ein paar normale Plays sehen.
Okay, die haben.
Das ist ja fast.
Hey, das ist ja fast wie in Warzone, wo die Leute manchmal anfangen mit dem Heli Roadkills zu machen.
As usual, I've got a few clips with blind enemy players.
Some fails and a few.
Da wird durchge-ge-gemixt.
Durchgeschnetzelt.
Now, is it just me or are these blind players quite rare to find when you play the game?
Whenever I play BF4, I never come across all of these blind players, but I do get sent in a lot of clips with them.
Ist der jetzt einfach für den Swag rausgesprungen, oder was?
Warum ist der eben aus dem Heli gesprungen?
Quite rare to find when you play the game yourself.
Whenever I play BF4, I never come across all of these blind players, but I do get sent in a lot of clips with them.
Warum?
Warum ist der eben aus dem Heli gesprungen?
Ergibt doch eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn, oder?
Weil es geht.
Flex.
All of these blind players, but I do get sent in a lot of clips with them.
Some funny ones in here.
Some lucky moments along the way.
The fails and the bugs.
Vor allem im Kopf mit der Panzergranate da.
Messer.
Das sind...
Okay, das ist legit.
Das ist legit.
Die Leute sind so dämlich und campen sich den Arsch ab in Battlefield teilweise, dass sie links und rechts nichts mitkriegen.
Und jetzt C4.
Jawoll.
Die kriegen echt wieder gar nichts mit.
Die kriegen gar nichts mit.
Oh, jetzt kommt der Borg.
Und schießt ihm in den Sack.
Nee.
Na, fast.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wow.
Okay, ich glaube, das habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Die Löcher bringen mal was.
Das war nice.
Okay, der fliegt gleich.
Der fliegt gleich.
Oder?
Oh.
What?
What the fuck?
Der L.A.V.
Der wird an der Stelle gesucht.
Gespawnt, oder?
Der L.A.V. wird gerade gespawnt vom Spiel.
Oder was macht der da?
Rekt, Alter.
Okay, das ist Fail.
Hä?
Ih, Battlefield 1.
Nee, ist gar nicht Battlefield.
Sah erst aus wie Battlefield 1.
Ist gar nicht Battlefield 4.
Was sehe ich da?
Das ist ein Jetski oder sowas.
Was ist das für eine Map?
Warum fliegt, warum fliegt da so ein Boot?
Ah, locker.
Das ist PS4, hä?
Bam, 5 Kills.
Hä?
What?
Was?
Pssst.
Hahaha.
What the fuck?
Irgendwie ist es cool, dass das einfach in Battlefield geht.
Das ist das Geile an Battlefield 3 und 4.
Und auch teilweise bei Complete 2.
Dass so ein Scheiß einfach halt geht.
Deswegen gab es so viele Sandbox-Dinge halt.
So Sachen, die ungescriptet einfach passiert sind.
Und das war auch so das Feeling, was du bei dem Game hattest.
Dass die Sachen halt nicht so passiert sind, weil vorher sich jemand überlegt hat, die müssen so passieren.
Sondern sie sind einfach durch die Verkettung von Gameplay aufgetreten.
Um heute das Video zu beenden, und wie ich gesagt habe, es war heute ein langes Video, habe ich 10 Minuten gespielt.
Und das war auch perfekt.
Nur in Battlefield-Moments, die ihr euch alle sendet.
Ich werde sie in den Hintergrund spielen, in einem Ultra-Battlefield-Montage, damit ihr wieder da seid und es genießt.
Wenn ihr irgendwelche Clips habt, die ihr selbst nicht gesehen habt, dann schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Top-Player bei Gmo.com.
Ich bringe sie nicht immer so hoch, aber wenn ich es tue, sind sie einfach unglaublich.
Danke fürs Zuschauen.
Genießt die nächsten 10 Minuten oder so von unglaublichen Battlefield-Moments.
Hoffentlich wird es euch in der Nähe bringen.
Ich fand das Video von ihm diesmal richtig gut.
Er hat nicht so viel erzählt.
Geht rein und spielt ein paar Battlefields selbst.
Und ich werde euch im nächsten Episode sehen.
Das, Moment, was?
Was ist das für eine Sprache?
Ist das Spanisch?
Das Armando.
Ist das Spanisch oder Portugiesisch?
Italienisch.
Das ist definitiv nicht Französisch.
Das ist...
Spanisch, okay.
Oh.
Huge Snipes.
Guckt euch mal an.
Die Kugel ist drei Kilometer groß.
Konsolen-Gameplay, lul.
Lul.
Oh, das war aber ein, ein, ein nicer Snipe.
Äh, Gredo, das wird nicht passieren.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es dazu führen würde, dass, dass, dass wieder meine Leute spielen.
Das war Dings hier, Addon.
Ähm, ich habe vergessen, wie es heißt.
War das Armored Kill?
Ne, war das, war das Armored Kill?
Ne, Armored Kill war Battlefield 3.
Oh, ich bringe es durcheinander.
Was ist jetzt los?
Was ist jetzt los im Hintergrund?
Hat er gerade den Gebetsteppich ausgepackt oder was?
Und...
Boah.
Okay, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass das noch hittet.
Final Stand.
Ja, das kann gut sein.
Ja, ja, das klingt gut.
Die Dinger zu treffen, ne, das würde ich nie gebacken kriegen.
Und ja, das stimmt.
Battlefield 4 und Battlefield 3.
Äh, sogar Bad Company 2 irgendwo.
Die sehen auch heutzutage noch okay aus.
Ist ja nicht so, dass das jetzt irgendwie schlecht wäre.
Zumal ich sie eh auf Low Settings spiele für Max FPS.
Battlefield 5 wurde Support eingestellt.
Ja.
Ja, weil sie es verkackt haben von Anfang an mit Battlefield 5.
Oho, voll in die Fresse.
Er kann sich nicht entscheiden, wo er spawnt.
Und snipen, snipen, snipen.
Wow, okay, das war Glück.
Dass der genoscoped hat, das war echt Glück.
Oh, mit Ankündigung.
Ja, und?
Und dann springen sie alle raus.
Und, und, und, trifft er nochmal?
Das könnte treffen, das könnte treffen.
Ja, Poggers.
Oh, my gosh.
I just did that.
Der hat ein bisschen Reaction-Verzögerung, kann das sein?
Guck mal.
Der fliegt hier runter.
Schießt nochmal.
Jetzt trifft er.
Eins, zwei,
drei, vier.
Oh, my gosh.
Der hat vier Sekunden Reaktionszeit.
Wie hat er das überhaupt getroffen?
I just did that.
Der wird rausgesniped aus dem Cockpit.
Bam.
Oh, that's nice.
Was zum, was ist das?
Was sehe ich hier?
Was ist das denn?
Kann mir das irgendeiner erklären?
Die Pods aus Final Stand.
Es kann sein, dass ich da nie drinnen war in so einem.
Es gab Drop Pods?
Die Map kenne ich noch.
Oh.
Ich meine, hübsch war das Game schon.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Also, ich meine, kann man nichts sagen.
Es sieht immer noch ziemlich gut aus.
Das ist wieder irgendeine Long Range, äh, ja.
Zack.
Wir haben jetzt eine Runde Spray in locker.
Und Gegner, die wieder
absolut nix checken.
Und der G18 war auch
eigentlich ziemlich OP,
aber trotzdem.
Die Gegner sind wieder, abs...
Aber so muss das sein!
Was meint ihr?
Wie meine 30-0 Free Falls früher in Call of Duty
entstanden sind?
Bestimmt nicht, weil ich so gute Gegner hatte.
Brauchst, du brauchst dumme Gegner für so Plays.
Ansonsten
Und so ein Crap wie in Modern Warfare, wo alle
eine 1er, 1er, 1er, 2er
KD haben.
Im Multiplayer.
Im normalen Multiplayer.
Oh, da werden sie
weggesprayt, Alter.
In your ass weggesprayt.
Tomal.
Hab ich glaube ich nie gespielt.
Weder Battlefield 3 noch Battlefield 4.
Oh.
Oh geil.
Das ist ja nice.
Moment, wo kommt das jetzt?
Ich meine, in dem Moment
denkst du dir, dreht euch nicht um.
Dreht euch nicht um.
Und jetzt.
Bam.
Lull.
Oh.
Mehr Glück als Verstand.
Der Heli,
der
mag auch nur geradeaus fliegen in einer Linie.
Ach, das sind wieder
die Typen hier auf dem Dings, die das ganze Game
nichts anders machen. Wisst ihr,
wenn ich die Runde gespielt hätte, würde mir das
voll auf den Keks gehen, weil die haben nicht zum
Rundenwin beigetragen. Definitiv nicht.
Die haben vielleicht mal den ein oder anderen Heli getroffen
irgendwann mal, aber es waren im Prinzip
einfach drei wasted Slots
im Team.
True. 0 W.
Schon wieder. Wie viele RPG-Kills
across the map von der Pose haben wir in diesem Video
jetzt schon gesehen?
Ja, wenn man ein ganzes Game sitzt, trifft
oder ganzen Tag sitzt, trifft man halt auch mal was.
Und jetzt und jetzt und jetzt.
Zack.
Nice.
Wie jeder sich freut.
Cooles Video.
Battlefield 1 versus
Battlefield 5. Juckt mich überhaupt nicht.
Juckt mich null.
So, was haben wir jetzt hier noch zur Auswahl?
Die härtesten
Super Nintendo Spiele. Der Linux-Vergleich.
Welche Distribution passt für euch?
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt, was er sagt.
Doom Eternal
Nightmare Speedruns.
Das hat nichts mit
diesen Glitch Speedruns zu tun,
sondern bei die
Ultra Nightmare Speedruns,
die spielen wirklich das Game von Anfang
bis Ende. Und das ist
teilweise echt heftig.
Die haben es wahnsinnig drauf.
Dann haben wir noch den Auer.
Irgendwas von Linus Tech Tips,
wo ich keine Ahnung habe, warum ich das aufgemacht habe
und was es da geht.
This is 15 times faster
than your PC. Holy shit!
Liquid Honey Badger.
War Honey Badger
nicht in Ghosts eine Waffe?
What happened to America
Online hätten wir auch noch zu bieten.
Ja, war es.
Okay.
Was gucken wir?
Was wollen wir gucken?
Leute, sagt was.
AOL.
Okay.
Speedrun.
Das ist auch kein Speedrun, das ist ein Speedrun Erklärungsvideo.
Linux.
Skelieron, Twitch Prime. Excellent.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Speedrun. Okay, wir gucken den Speedrun, danach gucken wir das Linux Video.
Muss mal kurz schauen,
dass ich nicht Subscriptions übersehen habe.
Das mache ich mal ganz gerne, wenn ich Videos gucke.
Der Gott Baba ist am Start.
Twitch Prime. Excellent.
Ich habe mich gerade an nichts verschluckt.
Geht auch.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ja, dann gucken wir erst das Speedrun Video.
Es geht 15 Minuten, danach gucken wir das Linux Video.
Was ein Intro.
Er hört sich schon ein bisschen Resident Sleeper an.
In der Quest, um es so schnell wie möglich zu beheben,
können Spieler über die Luft fliegen.
Genau, deswegen mag ich die normalen
Doom Eternal Speedruns nicht.
Aber die Ultra Nightmare Speedruns sind richtig nice.
Die Stimme ist ein bisschen Resident Sleeper.
Polar opposite in nature.
Speedruns, where glitches are not permitted.
The players must complete every aspect of the game in its entirety,
leaving no stone unturned.
Today we will be taking a look at one of Doom Eternals most difficult challenges.
Ja, aber das Gameplay ist ultra nice.
Also ich habe mal einen Doom Eternal Speedrun geguckt,
also einen Ultra Nightmare Speedrun.
Das geht irgendwie 2 Stunden oder so.
Und ist wirklich, gameplaytechnisch siehst du wirklich die Leute,
die haben es drauf.
Nightmare Category.
Konquering the Ultra Nightmare difficulty is tough enough as it is.
Enemies are deadlier than ever and if you die a single time, it's game over.
But when you throw in the element of speed, things get even crazier.
Despite the fact that Doom Eternal hosts a ton of secrets to find, collectables to obtain
and optional battles to overcome, the top Ultra Nightmare players are completing everything
in 3 hours or less.
Ah, 3 Stunden.
Ich bilde mir ein, es waren 2 Stunden, aber können auch 3 Stunden sein.
Ah, 3 Stunden. Ich bilde mir ein, es waren 2 Stunden, aber können auch 3 Stunden sein.
Also wenn hierbei nicht verpasst wird, heißt das es egal.
Das, genau, das ist nicht nur Ultra Nightmere, das ist 100% Ultra Nightmere.
expected full
They must have aim, the combat-flow of this game,
they must learn by heart where the enemies are located,
which weapons against whom they use,
that counting is crucial.
Yeah, it is.
Was sind die besten Waffen, die man benutzen kann? Welche Dämonen sollte man priorisieren?
Welche Techniken benutzen man, um die Enemien schnell zu ersetzen?
In diesem Video werden wir diese Fragen und mehr beantworten. Ich hoffe, ihr genießt es.
Jetzt, bevor wir weitergehen, kommt Vater's Day bald wieder und heute ist der Sponsor von Ridge Wallets...
Moment, ich muss mal kurz die Werbung überspringen.
...Code LEGEND. Der Link wird in der Beschreibung sein.
Raid Shadow Legends. Ne, nur Legend. Nur Legend diesmal.
...Ultra-Nightmare 100%. Was genau enthält das 100%?
Nun, hier ist eine Liste von allem, was der Spieler sammeln, entlocken oder vollenden muss.
Alle Waffen erzielt und alle Masteries für alle Mods erzielt.
Alle Sentinel-Kristalle-Übungen und alle Suit-Token-Übungen erzielt.
Alle sammelnabhängigen Items in der Fortress müssen veröffentlicht werden.
Alle Codex-Einträge erzielt und alle End-Level-Summaries-Screens...
Was? End-Level-Summaries-Screens müssen veröffentlicht werden?
Okay, wenn das wichtig ist, dass man nach dem Level alles durchklickt, alles klar.
...muss veröffentlicht werden und völlig veröffentlicht werden.
Nun, während große Glitches wie Slope-Boosting nicht explizit in der 100%-Kategorie veröffentlicht werden,
sind die Speedrunner, die diese Kategorie runnen, meistens Pyrus, die sich von ihren eigenen Exploiten verhindern.
Wie bei der Aufnahme dieses Videos, ist der aktuelle Weltrekord für Ultra-Nightmare 100%...
Ey, die haben es echt drauf.
...2 Stunden und 38 Minuten, veröffentlicht von Doom-Legend, Zero Master.
...auch wenn es aktuell eine starke Wettbewerb ist von Drakon...
...der nur ein paar Minuten hinter sich ist.
Beide Spieler wählen sich ab, von den großen Glitchen oder Makros zu verwandeln...
...und versuchen, sich dem originalen Geist des Spiels so vertraut zu machen, wie möglich.
Die Tatsache, dass jeder Wettbewerbspunkt veröffentlicht werden muss...
...die durch das Komplizieren der gesamten Wettbewerbs-Aranien...
Ja, ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, zweieinhalb Stunden.
Alle Upgrades, alle Waffen-Unlocks, alle Tokens, alle Lore-Kodex-Pages.
Zweieinhalb Stunden.
Soviel habe ich die ersten drei Level gemacht.
Soviel habe ich die ersten drei Levels gemacht.
Soviel habe ich die ersten drei Levels gespielt oder so.
...meinst, dass es die 100%-Kategorie ist, in der der Kampf wirklich bezeichnet wird.
Major-Skips werden fast unmöglich zu implementieren, da Skippen im Kampf...
Das ist sogar was, wo man sagen muss, ey, die müssen richtig gut aimen können.
Das ist ja auch was, was bei den meisten Speedruns jetzt nicht unbedingt so erforderlich ist.
Die müssen viel auswendig lernen und noch richtig gut aimen können.
Also eigentlich so ein richtiger Shooter-Speedrun, wie man ihn sich wünscht.
...Kampf wird die große Mehrheit des Rundtags besitzen...
...und deshalb...
...wird der ultimative Erfolg des Rundtags sehr abhängig davon sein, wie fähig der Spieler ist,
die Dämonen schnell zu eliminieren.
Kampf für Speed ist sehr anders als Kampf für Überlebensmöglichkeit.
Obwohl natürlich, dass man Dinge kurz hält, minimiert die Chancen, dass Dinge aus der Hand kommen.
Techniken, die völlig natürlich aussehen, sind auf der Tafel.
Zum Beispiel ist Glorikillen fast immer ein Fehler.
Sobald man einen Dämonen, der gesund genug ist, aufsteigt,
ist es viel schneller, es einfach zu schießen, um es zu beenden.
...und man natürlich jetzt auch weniger Leben und sowas bekommt dann.
Die einzigen Erweiterungen dazu sind die Kako-Dämonen im Spiel.
Sie sind extrem...
Heißen die wirklich Kako-Dämonen?
Nee, oder?
Das ist bestimmt einfach nur die englische Aussprache.
...durchschnittlich tankig, sodass sie mit einer einzigen Explosiv-Grenade
und einem Glorikill sehr effizient sind.
Nachher im Rundtag hat man aber Zugang zu den Ballisten,
die sie in einem Schuss beenden können.
Die andere Erweiterung sind Glorikillen,
die durchschnittlich in-Game-Challenges erfolgen müssen.
Stimmt, das müssen die auch noch machen.
Und was ich ganz vergessen habe,
was du bei einem 100% ja auch noch machen musst, ist,
100% musst du diese ganzen Kämpfe, die Zeitlimit haben, auch machen.
Es gibt doch immer zwischendurch diese Schlüssel,
wo man spezielle Kämpfe anlockt mit einem Zeitlimit.
Die musst du ja auch noch alle machen.
Okay, die müssen echt viel auswendig lernen,
wenn man Doom Eternal Ultra-Nightmare-Speedrunner werden will.
...Prozent-Requirement.
Die Weapon-Wheel ist auch raus,
weil es viel schneller ist, Hotkeys zu nutzen,
um zwischen jedem Waffen zu wechseln.
Zwischendurch zwischen verschiedenen Weapon-Kombinationen
ist extrem wichtig, wenn es um bestimmte Kampftechniken geht,
die wir sehr kurz darüber reden werden.
Wenn es um Weapon- und Suit-Upgrades,
Sentinel-Kristalle und Rune geht,
gibt es viele verschiedene Möglichkeiten,
welcher Art und Weise man wählen kann.
Während es eine Requisition ist,
dass alles endlich geupgradiert wird,
sind bestimmte Upgrades wertvoller als andere,
also werden sie zuerst ausgewählt.
Während Tech-Tree-Priorität
letztendlich demonstrabler geschlossen werden kann,
ist es viel zu früh,
dass alles genau getestet wird.
Spieler wissen genau,
welchen Art und Weise sie die Upgrades auflösen,
und es scheint,
dass es für einige universelle Verträge gibt.
Wenn es um Weapon-Mods geht,
ist generell nur einer für jedes Waffen verwendet,
weil der Zeitraum,
für den Mod zu wechseln,
verwendet wird.
Generell sind die folgenden Mods verwendet.
Für den Kampf-Schotgun
sind Sticky-Bomben verwendet,
als effektiver Weg,
um weichere Mobs zu beheben
und...
damit habe ich auch gespielt.
Hab ich auch benutzt?
Boah, ich hab schon die Speedrun-Strats drauf hier.
Unbewusst.
Hab ich auch benutzt.
Boah, ich sag's euch hier.
Max Speedrun-Strats
schon am Start,
obwohl er nie Speedrun wollte.
Hab ich auch benutzt!
Äh, weiß nicht mehr,
was ich benutzt hab.
5ennen Austausch
Ja, das war auch eine der ersten Sachen,
die ich angeloggt hab.
Ohwell, gut.
Also gerade bei 100% musst du dir extrem viel merken.
Wenn die sterben ist der Run vorbei, oder?
Weil, das kannst du doch nicht mehr Recoveren.
Das kostet dich ja gleich 3-4 Minuten.
Guck mal, also man sieht, du musst in dem Speedrun wirklich aimen können.
Quickscoped hier, hala.
Ja.
Ich glaube, dass das, so wie die spielen, wirklich der Weg ist, wie sich das Entwickler
auch gedacht haben, wie man das Spiel spielt.
Was?
Wtf?
MonkaS?
Das geht?
Der Yeet-Hook.
Haha.
Ja.
Der Yeet-Hook.
Genau.
Aber genau.
Stimmt.
Stimmt ein.
Dann muss man den Yeet-Hook.
Ja.
Genau.
Wie ich vorhin erwähnt habe, ist die Lock-On-Mode der beste Wahl, um schwerere Dämonen auszulösen.
Und einige von ihnen brauchen extra Schaden, um getötet zu werden.
Also ist generell ein Schuss mit einer präzisen Bolte oder Super-Schotgun genutzt, um sie auszulösen.
Aber eine Lock-On-Blast plus eine Frag-Grenade ist eine viel bessere Option.
Denn nachdem die Rockets und Grenaden getötet wurden, kann man sofort auf die nächste Dämonin bewegen.
Ballista-Boosting ist auch genutzt, um schnell herum zu gehen und größere Jumps zu machen.
Dies nimmt den großen Recoil und bietet einen dezenten Speed-Boost, wenn man schießt, während man im Mittelland ist.
Wissen, was es ist, um zu wissen, wie die Enemies und Waffen funktionieren, ist etwas, was jeder Runner umsetzen muss.
Aber am Ende des Tages, es all das zu der Exekution beiträgt.
Jeder verpasste Schuss kostet Zeit.
Also wird die Akkuratität als die größte Variable sein.
Die Top-Player haben extrem viel Versuch.
Und es ist ein Teil der Reise in die Top-Player.
Und es funktioniert ja folgendermaßen.
Du hast ja verschiedene Mechaniken im Spiel.
Du kannst, wenn die Gegner so golden leuchten, kannst du sie killen.
Du kriegst ein bisschen, ich glaube, Leben.
Du kannst die Gegner anzünden.
Und wenn du so killst, kriegst du ein bisschen Ammo.
Nicht Ammo, Ammo.
Wenn du die Gegner schnetzelst, mit der Kettensäge, kriegst du Munition.
Und das musst du quasi im passenden Rhythmus ausführen.
Und auf Ultra Nightmare.
Auf Ultra Nightmare sind die Gegner auch viel stärker.
Und du hältst auch insgesamt weniger aus.
Also das ist echt nicht ohne.
Die sind wirklich ziemlich gut, die Runner.
Doom Eternal ist so entzündend zu sehen.
Wenn Doom Eternal gut gespielt wird, ist es einfach wunderschön.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, was passiert gerade alles auf einmal.
Exzellent.
Der weiß halt echt überall, wo was steht.
Und das muss er erst mal zwei Stunden durchhalten.
Der hat's halt voll drauf, der Dude, ey.
Ja, die Musik ist echt nice.
In dieser bestimmten Arena sind es drei Wälder.
Und obwohl es auf jeden Fall viele weniger Dämonen gibt,
müssen nur bestimmte Dämonen getötet werden, um jede Wälder zu beenden.
Die erste Wälder sind zwei Cyberman-Kubais.
Ein Revenant und ein Hellknight.
Die zweite Wälder enthält...
Genau, und du musst erst mal die Quickscopes in der Luft und so auch treffen.
Also, dazu gehört schon ein bisschen was.
Once those demons have been eliminated, the arena will open.
As soon as he enters, he will list a boost to the location of the first spawn, a Cyberman-Kubis.
These demons are protected by high amounts of armor, but are weak to the Blood Punch,
which Zeromaster uses to break its armor and deal significant damage.
He then switches between the Super-Shotgun and Heavy Cannon to finish it off.
The next target is a Revenant, where Zeromaster uses the Rocket Launcher Lock-On...
Und wisst ihr, was das Coolste daran ist?
Dass es genau so ist, wie sich das die Entwickler gedacht haben.
Die haben ja nicht umsonst eingebaut, dass der Nahkampfangriff was gegen die Armor macht,
dass das gegen jenes was macht.
Genauso, ich gehe ziemlich...
Wenn das sich ein Entwickler angucken würde, würde der wahrscheinlich sagen,
genau so haben wir uns das vorgestellt.
Und das ist doch cool, wenn mal...
Wenn das wirklich mal übereinstimmt, so.
However, he only has two rockets, which isn't enough to kill it.
So he needs to quick switch to the Super-Shotgun to do more damage.
He then jumps down and chainsaws the second Cyberman-Kubis.
Using the chainsaw to eliminate certain heavy demons is embedded into the strategy,
but requires a lot of planning, as you need to save up the three bars of fuel needed.
With the ammo obtained from the Man-Kubis,
he switches back to the Rocket Launcher and uses the Lock-On to kill the Hell Knight.
This begins the second wave, and he immediately runs to the spawn of the Baron
to take it out with the Crucible.
Again, saving Crucible charges for the heaviest demons is important,
and where each charge will be used is planned in advance.
Unfortunately, a glitch occurs here where the Crucible attacks again,
wasting a charge on an Imp.
There are still a few annoying bugs in Eternal which haven't yet been resolved,
which can cause some hiccups.
This wasted charge won't impact this run immediately,
but it does mean time will be lost somewhere in a future battle.
Zero Master then uses a Lock-On to kill the Whiplash
and an Arbalest Shot to take out the Cacodemon.
Now there is a slight delay before the next wave spawns,
so he takes out a couple of drones to collect ammo and armor.
When the third wave appears, the Crucible was again used to take out the Baron,
followed by a Lock-On and Frag grenade to take out a Whiplash.
He then heads through the portal to the other side of the arena,
where the second Whiplash should be.
But in this case, there were a couple of time losses previously during the fight,
which meant that it had already moved away.
He shifts focus to the Cacodemon, taking it out with the Arbalest,
and then searches for the remaining Whiplash,
which after a few seconds is found and destroyed.
Master 2090, ballern bis die Aliens kommen, ja?
Aber dazu muss man erst einen Clan besuchen.
Nur wenn man einen Clan besucht, geht das.
With a Lock-On.
In this case, being slightly behind schedule,
didn't cause any detrimental harm,
it was merely a few seconds of time loss.
However, if things don't go as planned,
combat can quickly get out of hand and spiral out of control.
As a spectator, top-level Doom Eternal combat
is some of the most entertaining gameplay out there.
While the initial wave of excitement over Doom Eternal seems to have washed away,
I believe that competitive play will begin to snowball in popularity as time goes on.
I've put a link in the description to Zero Masters' full Ultra Nightmare 100% run,
so definitely go and give that one a watch.
A huge thanks to Zero Master as well for letting me use his footage throughout the video.
The guy is truly an absolute legend,
and is in my opinion the greatest Doom player of all time.
I may even devote an entire video to his accomplishments in the near future.
Thanks again to the guys in the Doom Eternal Speedrunning Discord
for continuing to help me learn more about this game.
Thank you so much for watching, you legends.
I hope you are having a fantastic day,
and I will see you in the next video.
Peace out.
Subtitles by the Amara.org community
Der hat nackig nen Mario 64 World Record Speedrun gemacht.
Nicht schlecht.
Okay, er hat bestimmt ne Hose an oder so, aber ist nicht übel.
Warum gibt es auf speedrun.com keine Ultra Nightmare?
Hat der mal nen Link zu dem Run?
Ah, okay.
Okay, es gibt wenigstens halbwegs ordentlich Views.
Die submitten das klar?
Glaub ich einfach nicht.
Achso, Moment, Any%
Ich hab's nicht gesehen, weil mein Darkreader die Seite kaputt macht.
Ah.
Ja, aber trotzdem nicht die richtigen...
Nicht das Richtige.
Und die laden das wahrscheinlich...
Wahrscheinlich lassen die das nicht verifien.
Weil das Video auf YouTube war 2.28.
Aber trotz...
Ach nee, 2.28.
Ah, okay.
Dann uploaden die das doch.
Ach, was auch immer.
Ist aber nice, dass man wenigstens ein paar Views davon bekommt.
Ich komm immer noch nicht drüber klar, dass der nackig Mario 64 gestreamt hat.
Das ist so einfach nackig vom Rechner.
Im Stream, Alter.
Yolo, juckt ihn nicht.
Juckt ihn nicht.
Stimmt, der hat immerhin ne Brille auf.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns das auf das Lilux Video an.
Wundervollen guten Tag und herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Moment, hatten wir den nicht eben schon mal?
Willkommen zu einem riesigen Linux-Distributions-Vergleich.
Riesig, 15 Minuten, okay.
Excellent.
Mal gucken, aber das...
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie er das sieht.
Das ist ja ein Thema, wo ich mich schon auch öfters drüber ausgelassen habe.
Mit welcher Linux-Distribution kann man anfangen?
Was ist wie hier für Fortgeschrittene?
Was ist da für...
Da hab ich mich auch schon öfters drüber ausgelassen.
Mal gucken, was die dazu sagen.
... und zwar Linux ist nicht ein System,
sondern es gibt unfassbar viele Linux-Distributionen.
Ja.
Und Distribution meint hier sowas wie alternative Systeme.
Es gibt nicht das Linux, sondern ihr habt die Wahl zwischen sehr, sehr vielen Dingern.
Das ist korrekt.
Die vielleicht für eure Zwecke gut sind, aber für jemand anders nicht so gut.
Und das kommt stark darauf an, was ihr eigentlich machen wollt.
Hast du den Half-Life 1 Weltrekord mitbekommen, wo der Runner nebenbei noch ein anderes Game gelernt hat?
Nein? Hast du mal einen Link? Hab ich nicht mitbekommen.
Können wir gucken.
Was euer System denn eigentlich können soll.
Was eure Hardware von sich gibt.
Und so weiter und so fort.
Das kann man bei Windows...
Also wenn du einen Link hast, gucken wir mal rein.
Captain Peng.
Du hast deinen ersten Raspberry Pi bekommen.
Excellent.
Hast du schon was spezielles vor?
Es gibt einen Windows 10, die anderen sind einfach alle nicht mehr aktuell.
Das ist bei Linux anders.
Dadurch, dass Linux wirklich offen ist und jeder sich sein eigenes Linux erstellen kann...
Link gespeichert.
... gibt es da natürlich auch über 250.000.
Oder 200 verschiedene davon.
Und wir wollen uns heute wirklich einige davon mal angucken.
Ja, wie versprochen, sehr, sehr viele Systeme, die wir uns heute ganz kurz alle nur angucken wollen.
Ich werde nicht erklären, was die alle so besorgen.
Und das reicht hinten und vorne nicht.
Es gibt noch viel, viel, viel, viel, viel mehr.
... anders macht oder so.
Sondern ich will sie nur ein kleines bisschen einordnen in verschiedene Kategorien,
sodass ihr vielleicht einen kleinen Guide habt, welches System für euch am besten geeignet ist.
Das gesagt, hier muss...
SteamOS fehlt noch.
... auch noch dazu sagen, alles ist eigentlich mit jedem Linux-System möglich.
Ihr habt nicht ein Linux, das überhaupt nichts kann, sozusagen.
Oder ein Linux, das zum Beispiel...
Echt?
Wo?
Links.
Ah!
Habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Excellent.
Ich meine, ich kenne niemanden, der SteamOS verwendet, ne?
... den man nicht programmieren kann.
Oder ein Linux, auf dem man...
Blind, ja.
... nicht zocken kann.
Weil...
Ist so.
Nein.
Man kann...
Das ist das schlechteste Logo.
Das ist das schlechteste Logo, was ich seit langem gesehen habe, Alter.
EasyOS.
Das sieht wirklich mies aus.
Im Grunde fast alles mit fast allen Systemen machen.
Es gibt einige...
Das ist richtig.
Da sind manche Systeme einfach sehr, sehr eingeschränkt.
Aber das ist dann auch so gewollt.
Und das heißt...
Das hier ist eher so eine Richtlinie.
Und ja, die Systeme kommen natürlich mit einem gewissen Umfang.
Das heißt, wie ist die Installation erstmal?
Wie ist zum Beispiel auch die erste Nutzererfahrung?
Und dementsprechend habe ich die mal versucht, hier einzuordnen.
So.
Da das jetzt alles sehr, sehr...
Nun ja, unübersichtlich ist, habe ich mal versucht, hier ein paar Kategorien zu machen.
Irgendwie erinnert mich die Stimme von jemand irgendwem.
Mir fällt bloß grad nicht ein, an wen.
Und die Systeme da so ein kleines bisschen einzuteilen.
Wir sehen...
Massive Effekte.
Auf der linken Seite sind eher die Systeme, die Anfänger verwenden.
Auf der rechten Seite sind eher die Systeme, die die Profis verwenden.
Und das ist jetzt...
Okay, da muss ich mal kurz gucken, ob was...
Okay.
Also, zeigt mal her.
Ähm...
Anfänger.
Oh Leute, wir sind Anfänger.
FeelsBatman.
Okay, also.
Ja, gebe ich dem voll und ganz recht.
Hier Ubuntu, Elementary, Mint.
Ganz klar Anfängersysteme.
Manjaro auch.
Ja.
Das ist wirklich ein super Einsteiger-System, wenn man Artstellungs haben will.
Kann ich nur empfehlen.
Äh...
Moin Kosta.
Ubuntu.
Lubu...
Lubuntu.
Peppermint kenne ich nicht.
Xubuntu.
Kubuntu.
Was auch immer.
Äh...
OpenSUSE.
Oh, geht immer auf.
Ja, aber da...
Das würde ich auch...
Würde ich so unterschreiben, wie das hier...
Für alte Geräte.
Da gab's früher noch Puppi-Linux und sowas für...
Ja, so...
Was für alte Geräte.
Ja.
Stimmt.
Würde ich auch so sagen.
Ist der Kali vor allem?
Ja.
Klar.
Äh...
Für die Big-Brain-Fraktion hier hinten.
Ähm...
Gentoo.
Das war...
Für alle...
Für alle, die gerne die drei Stunden kompilieren, bis sie einen Mail-Anhang öffnen können.
Wobei, wer öffnet heutzutage Mail-Anhänge?
Äh...
Für alle, die es komplett gerne selbst bauen.
Von Krux habe ich noch nie was gehört.
Das Logo sieht aber auch echt...
Äh...
Naja, gut.
Anhand des Logos kann man das Projekt jetzt nicht bewerten.
Äh...
Ein richtiges Art-Linux und Void-Linux.
Ja.
Das sind hier die ganzen...
Ähm...
Security...
Äh...
Anonymität.
Nicht Security.
Die Anonymitäts-Geschichten.
Das ist ja das, was Snowden sogar mal empfohlen hat, glaube ich.
Tails.
Ähm...
Cubes.
Das ist dieses...
Ähm...
Wo alles...
Wo alles in extra...
Äh...
Xen-VMs läuft.
Hunix habe ich noch nie gehört.
Knobix.
Live-CD.
Ja.
Och.
So.
Und dann noch vieles dazwischen.
Gaming.
SteamOS.
Special Interest.
Auch probiert.
Scientific-Linux.
Scientific-Linux gibt es, glaube ich, nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, das wurde eingestellt.
Ja.
Aber...
Mit der Einteilung kann ich...
Kann ich nur sagen...
Ja.
Finde ich...
Hat er gut gemacht.
Würde ich auch so machen.
So oder so ähnlich.
Excellent.
Irgendwie gewertet.
Also, wenn man jetzt ein Profi-System nutzt, dann heißt das nicht unbedingt, dass man
mehr machen kann.
Ähm...
Ja.
Matze fragt eine gute Frage.
Warum Manjaro als Anfänger?
Es basiert doch auf Arch.
Und Arch ist...
Ja, das stimmt.
Es ist Arch viel komplizierter einzurichten als Manjaro.
Und Manjaro hat noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Sie haben beispielsweise eigene Repos dazwischen, dass man nicht mehr die komplett...
Also Manjaro-Pakete sind manchmal so zwei Wochen verzögert oder so.
Also man kriegt nicht die volle Bleeding-Edge-Ladung wie in Arch, sondern schon die bisschen ausgeblutete
Ladung in Manjaro.
Ähm...
Aber Manjaro ist auch ein System, was wirklich für Einsteiger...
Was man verwenden kann, wenn man ein bisschen interessiert ist.
Ich finde, man kann es nicht auf das gleiche Level stellen wie jetzt...
Ein Linux-Mint oder so.
Ein Linux-Mint ist ein System, was wirklich fast jeder Noob, der nicht komplett zwei linke
Hände verbinden kann, äh...
Verwenden kann.
Manjaro nicht.
Allein schon die Manjaro-Installation ist bisschen hakelig.
Da sieht man, da haben keine Leute dran gesessen, die jetzt wirklich viel Wert auf eine Noob-verständliche
Installation gemacht haben.
Aber...
Manjaro ist...
Ähm...
Komplett Arch-Linux von Hand installieren immer noch viel, viel angenehmer.
Man könnte...
Man könnte Manjaro eher so...
Eher so hier so dazwischen irgendwie anorten, zwischen Profi und Anfänger.
Wobei man halt sagen muss, generell so die Unterscheidung zwischen Anfänger und Profi
ist halt die Frage.
Es ist ja nicht so, als könnte man mit einem Profi-System jetzt so viel mehr machen, als
mit einem Anfänger-System.
Ich verwende Manjaro hauptsächlich, weil es ein Arch-Linux ist.
Ähm...
Aber ein paar Sachen einfacher sind.
Ja, dadurch wird es auch anfängerfreundlicher.
Aber letztendlich verdiene ich...
Tagtäglich mein Geld unter anderem damit, dass ich Linux verwende.
Also...
Gerade das...
Äh...
Ist ja das, was man quasi unter Pro bezeichnet.
Jemand, der mit einer gewissen Sache sein Geld verdient.
Und man kann auch als Pro, in Anführungsstrichen, ein Anfänger-Betriebssystem nehmen und damit
sein Geld verdienen.
Kein Problem.
... als mit einem Anfänger-System.
Im Endeffekt kann man auch mit einem Anfänger-System wirklich alles tun, wie...
Siehste?
Genau das sagt er ja auch.
Hat er recht.
Und...
Dann sind einfach die Profi-Systeme viel, viel umständlicher.
Teilweise sind sie einfacher eben zu bedienen.
Aber...
Es ist eher so die Nutzer-Erfahrung.
Wie viel Wissen braucht man?
Wie stark muss man sich durch irgendwelche Anleitungen wühlen?
Und es funktioniert auch wirklich gut.
Wie gesagt, ich verwende auf der Arbeit seit Jahren nur noch Manjaro.
Überhaupt kein Problem.
Funktioniert wunderbar.
Hat drei Notebook-Generationen überlebt.
... mit dem Terminal machen.
So habe ich das ungefähr mal eingeteilt.
So.
Also nochmal ganz kurz zu den Anfänger-Systemen.
Wir sehen oben links das SteamOS.
Und das ist wirklich ein System, was nur zum Zocken geeignet ist.
Das ist quasi der Big-Picture-Modus von Steam.
Mehr ist das System nicht.
Und das läuft als Linux auf einem Rechner, wo man dann zum Beispiel zocken kann.
Ich empfehle dieses System tatsächlich nicht unbedingt.
Ich auch nicht.
Weil es...
Also klar, mit SteamOS kann man sehr, sehr viel und sehr, sehr gut zocken.
Aber wenn man Gamer ist, dann wird man natürlich auch Maus und Tastatur zum Beispiel hauptsächlich verwenden wollen zum Zocken.
Und ich persönlich mag einfach den Big-Picture-Modus.
Ich mag den Big-Picture-Modus nicht.
Aber das hat hier nicht wirklich was damit zu tun.
Man kann auch zum Beispiel keine Epic-Games-Spiele zocken.
Oder eben andere Spiele.
Ja, zum Spielen ist Linux nach wie fair...
... ja...
... naja.
... wirklich nur die Steam-Spiele.
Also zum Zocken vielleicht ein anderes Linux nehmen.
Eventuell, wenn man spielen will, by the way, einfach ein Windows nehmen.
Fertig.
Und man hat keine Probleme mehr.
Auf einem anderen Linux kann man genauso Steam installieren.
Wie auch auf SteamOS.
Es sei denn, man möchte Super Tox Card spielen.
Aber vielleicht noch interessanter, links unten, die Anfängersysteme.
Ich empfehle meistens Manjaro oder Linux Mint für wirkliche Anfänger.
Allerdings sind die beiden relativ verschieden.
Linux Mint würde ich Anfängern auch empfehlen.
Manjaro nicht.
Manjaro eigentlich nicht.
Also wenn wirklich jemand sagt, hey, ich verwende hauptsächlich Windows, mache aber jetzt nicht so viele Sachen, die Windows-only-Software erfordern.
So die Basic-Sachen von Surfen bis ein bisschen YouTube-Videos gucken und sowas.
Dem würde ich ganz klar sagen, probiere mal eine Linux Mint aus und schau, wie es dir gefällt.
Aber, und das muss man auch allen Anfängern immer sagen, denk nicht, dass man das gleich verwenden kann wie Windows.
Es hat doch viele Unterschiede.
... Video gemacht.
Was denkst du zu Chrome OS?
Eigentlich nichts.
... noch genauer drauf eingehen.
Man hat hier aber natürlich auch noch andere Systeme wie Elementry, Zorin OS, Ubuntu...
Oh, Zorin hat mir gar nicht gefallen.
... Linux OS, der Name ist wirklich furchtbar.
Dann Lubuntu und MX Linux, genauso wie Magaya und OpenSUSE, Kubuntu, Linux Lite und Xubuntu sind eigentlich alles Anfängersysteme.
Alles klar.
Da kann man einfach mal nach dem jeweiligen...
Klingt wie irgendwie Schwedisch oder so.
... System googeln.
Und dann kann man da schon ein paar Bilder sehen.
Und vielleicht ist das eine Bild ansprechender als das andere.
Und dementsprechend kann man sich hier für ein System entscheiden.
Es gibt hier nicht wirklich...
Die Kautz, gute Frage, fragt, wenn es um Linux neben Windows nutzen geht, lieber einfach eine VM für Linux oder Dualboot?
Es kommt drauf an, was du machen willst unter Linux.
In der Regel würde ich sagen, fang mit einer VM an und guck, ob es dir reicht.
Weil eine Linux-VM unter Windows zu betreiben, ist deutlich angenehmer als Dualboot.
Wenn man halt auch Windows-Sachen braucht.
Aber wenn du Zugriff auf deine Hardware brauchst, dann ist halt mit VM nicht wirklich.
Ich würde mit einer VM anfangen.
Hast auch den Vorteil, wenn du was kaputt machst, ist nicht schlimm.
... als, sondern es gibt nur Alternativen zu.
Und genau so...
Das stimmt, da hat er recht, da hat er recht.
Was euch besser gefällt, ist definitiv die bessere Wahl.
Die Systeme, die ich jetzt hier nicht eingeordnet habe, die in der Mitte liegen,
das sind Systeme, die so allrounder sind.
Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass die Anfängersysteme nicht auch allrounder sind,
aber die Systeme in der Mitte sind vielleicht nicht ganz so...
Leute, jetzt war mal Big-Brain-Frage.
Welche der Distributionen, die hier gezeigt werden, ist die älteste?
Welches ist hier die älteste Linux-Distribution?
XD kennt sich aus.
Leute, ihr habt... Chat.
Also man muss sagen, die vielen Subscriber haben geholfen.
Der IQ ist so hoch, dass die erste richtige Antwort Slackware ist.
Korrekt.
Die Anfängersysteme, zumindest meiner Erfahrung nach.
Also der Chat ist wirklich heute wieder außer sich vor Gehirnleistung.
Ne, Slackware.
Unten eine Kategorie für alte Geräte.
Alte Geräte bedeutet, wir haben zum Beispiel einen wirklichen PC, der jetzt 10 Jahre oder 15 Jahre alt ist.
Pentium 2. Pentium 2.
Ich habe mal vor 5 Jahren oder so mal auf dem Pentium 2 400...
Ne, das ist schon länger her.
Wobei...
Ja doch, 5 Jahre könnte hinkommen.
Vor 5 Jahren habe ich mal auf dem Pentium 2 400 aus Spaß an der Freude Puppi-Linux installiert.
Das ging erstaunlich gut.
Dort läuft vielleicht nicht die stärkste Hardware drauf.
Trotzdem möchte man diesen PC vielleicht nicht wegschmeißen, sondern irgendwas damit machen.
Und dazu gibt es dann eben die 3 Systeme.
Die 3 Systeme Lubuntu, MX-Linux und Antix.
Das sind wirklich Systeme, die für ältere Geräte optimiert sind und dementsprechend auch nicht so viel Ressourcen...
Also ich habe immer Puppi-Linux verwendet für alte Geräte.
...so schön aussehen.
Ja, oben habe ich eine Kategorie aufgemacht.
Ich wusste leider keinen besseren Namen.
Die habe ich jetzt mal Special Interest genannt.
Die sind tatsächlich für sehr, sehr spezielle Bedürfnisse.
Also zum Beispiel Bedrock kombiniert Features...
...von Arch-Linux mit Debian zum Beispiel.
Und noch ein paar andere dazu.
Scientific-Linux ist wirklich für Science ausgelegt.
Ähm, Red Hat...
Nee, Scientific-Linux ist nicht wirklich für Science ausgelegt.
Scientific-Linux ist ein Red Hat Klon.
Beziehungsweise ein CentOS.
Red Hat, Scientific, CentOS.
Also CentOS und Scientific-Linux sind quasi Red Hat Nachbauten...
...wenn man keine Red Hat Lizenzen kauft.
Wenn man keine Red Hat Lizenzen kaufen will.
...Betreuung und EasyOS ist zum Feature ausprobieren gedacht.
Also nicht einfach, aber einfach neue Features ausprobieren.
Deswegen der Name EasyOS.
PopOS ist für Entwickler gedacht.
Aber trotzdem kann man natürlich mit all diesen Systemen...
PopOS hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Da war nichts von dem in der aktuellen Version dabei...
...was ich zum entwickeln gebraucht hätte.
Außer Visual Studio Code.
PopOS hat mir nur gefallen.
Aber ich glaube, dass man das auch mit Linux machen könnte.
So, dann haben wir in der Mitte den großen Block.
Live-System, Anonymität und direkt drunter IT-Security.
Also Pentesting und Forensik.
Für Pentesting und Forensik gibt es drei Systeme.
Im Endeffekt Parrot OS, Kali Linux und Black Arch.
Was? Parrot OS?
Black Arch basiert logischerweise auf Arch Linux.
Kali basiert auf Debian.
Und Parrot OS erfüllt gleichzeitig noch ein paar Anonymitätsfragen.
Die, naja, von Tails auch erfüllt werden.
Von Cubes OS erfüllt werden.
Und von Hunix erfüllt werden.
Parrot OS habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Noch nie gehört.
Wobei Tails einen ganz großen anderen Weg geht.
Cubes und Hunix sind allerdings schon halbe Profisysteme.
Die sind wirklich gar nicht so einfach richtig aufzusetzen und zu benutzen.
Ja, Cubes ist eher so ein Experiment, würde ich sagen.
Weil alles in Xen4M läuft.
...hab ich auch schon ein Tutorial gemacht.
Tails hingegen nimmt den Ansatz, dass es ein Live-System ist.
Live-Systeme sind tatsächlich...
...man startet sie...
...man startet sie von der CD oder dem USB-Stick.
CD, Alter.
Man fährt den PC hoch.
Man macht, was man machen möchte.
Man fährt ihn runter.
Und der PC hat sich absolut gar nichts gemerkt.
Also es gibt quasi kein Festplattenspeichern bei Live-Systemen.
Das ist sehr gut für Security oder für Anonymität, um genau zu sein.
Weswegen Tails diesen Ansatz hier geht.
CD in 2020.
Aber auf der anderen Seite von Knoppix geht diesen Ansatz auch um eben hier noch ein...
...also es ist eigentlich auch ein richtiges System.
Aber Knoppix wird normalerweise...
Knoppix wird normalerweise dazu verwendet, um Sachen wiederherzustellen.
Das heißt, wenn man irgendwie...
Derjenige, der mir den Poki-Sub geschenkt hat, hieß auch Morpheus.
Ich entdecke da Zusammenhänge.
...Systemverlust hatte oder sowas, dann kann man da supergut einen Knoppix nehmen.
Das Ding ist allerdings, Live-Systeme werden auch mit allen anderen Linux-Systemen eigentlich mitgeliefert.
Das heißt, man kann jedes Linux erstmal von der CD beziehungsweise dem USB-Stick starten...
...und dann mal ausprobieren.
Aber man hat normalerweise noch die Funktion, das System zu unterstützen.
Tails zum Beispiel hat diese Funktion gar nicht.
Also man kann Tails nur auf dem USB-Stick installieren, in Anführungsstrichen.
Man kann nichts speichern.
Das ist aber auch wirklich der Sinn von Tails.
Sozusagen sieht man sogar schon im Logo.
Ja, ganz rechts sehen wir da noch ein paar Profi-Systeme.
Die sind auf Profis ausgelegt.
Also wirklich für Leute, die sich ihr Linux so anpassen wollen, wie sie das gerade brauchen.
Und dementsprechend sind sie auch nicht ganz so einfach.
Das heißt, Linux from scratch, also kurz LFS genannt, das ist tatsächlich...
...man baut sich seine eigene Linux-Distribution zusammen.
Gentoo ist auch wirklich ein sehr komplexes System.
Gentoo ist für die Leute, die gerne eine halbe Stunde kompilieren, bevor sie einen Mail-Anhang öffnen können.
...benutze eigentlich, ist auch ein System, was bei der Installation nicht ganz das einfachste System ist.
Also die würde ich tatsächlich nur raten...
...wenn man wirklich schon mit Linux gearbeitet hat.
Also nicht als erstes System.
Als erstes System bitte eins aus der linken Hälfte hier wählen.
Und dementsprechend kann man jetzt hier eigentlich schon recht gut rauslesen, welche Systeme ganz gut geeignet sind...
...und welche vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so gut geeignet sind.
Noch ein kleiner weiterer Hinweis hier.
Es gibt bei Linux einzelne Systeme, die...
Krasse Animation.
Nun ja, erstmal quasi Elternsysteme sind.
Also die erstmal sozusagen als...
Ja.
Knoppix, war Knoppix nicht mal ein Debian?
...Bild für andere Systeme dienen.
Und hier ein ganz großes Beispiel ist Debian.
Das ist ein System, aus dem haben sich so viele weitere Systeme entwickelt.
Das ist der Hammer.
Ubuntu zählt schon fast als sein eigenes System, obwohl es eigentlich auf Debian basiert.
Und ja, auf Ubuntu basieren dann Lubuntu, Xubuntu, Kubuntu.
Kali Linux bzw. Kali Linux basiert auch auf Debian.
Da gibt es zwei Varianten und so weiter und so fort.
Das sind sozusagen die Ursprünge, die sich da wirklich rauskristallisiert haben.
Aber das nur so mal am Rande.
Jetzt ist natürlich noch eine weitere große Frage im Raum und zwar...
Ja, Rolling Releases.
Elstar sagt, wo ist macOS?
Irgendwo hier rechts vom Monitor.
Fixed Releases.
Das ist quasi das Release-Modell von Linux-Distribution.
Oh, jetzt will er es wissen.
Und die markierten Systeme hier, die haben das Rolling Release.
Das ist nicht zwangsläufig besser.
Es ist nur eine alternative Art und Weise.
Das bedeutet erstmal ganz kurz, Fixed Release bedeutet, so wie bei Windows.
Man hat ein Windows 8, Windows 9, Windows 10, Windows 11, Windows 12, Windows 13, 14, 15, 16.
Man hat einfach...
Windows 16.
Die dann große Updates sind sozusagen.
Und über diese großen Updates ändert sich natürlich einiges.
Das heißt, man muss sein System aber auch immer mal wieder wirklich groß updaten.
Oder im Zweifelsfall sogar neu installieren.
Das ist das, was quasi ein Fixed Release-Modell beschreibt.
Okay.
Bei Rolling Releases gibt es das nicht.
Rolling Releases haben...
Arch Linux ist quasi der berühmteste Vertreter.
Und alle, die oder die meisten von Arch Linux abstammen, haben eigentlich ein Rolling Release.
Und das bedeutet wirklich Software, die veröffentlicht wird, kommt relativ schnell auch als Patch für den Nutzer dann.
Ja, und es geht auch relativ schnell kaputt.
Das muss einem klar sein.
Deswegen mag ich das bei Manjaro.
Manjaro hat nochmal so Zwischenrepos, dass man nicht die komplette Kacke abkriegt, die da am Dampfen ist.
Oder wie sagen sie ganz gerne immer auf Englisch?
Shit hits the fan.
Das ist so eine unglaublich dumme Redewendung, by the way.
Auf das System.
Shit hits the fan.
Das heißt, wenn jetzt gerade in diesem Moment ein Update für zum Beispiel eine Programmiersprache rauskommt, die ich häufig benutze.
Ich würde jetzt einfach mal pfeifen, wenn jetzt da die neue Version rauskommt, dann habe ich die eigentlich innerhalb von wenigen Tagen schon auf meinem Rechner.
Während auf Fixed Release Modellen, da kann es eine ganz schöne Weile dauern, bis ich dann auch wirklich was habe.
Klar natürlich, die Patches, die wirklich wichtig sind, die kommen dann relativ schnell.
Also sowas wie Schwachstellen oder Security Issues, die werden dann trotzdem relativ schnell gepatcht.
Aber große neue Versionen, die etwas kaputt machen könnten,
die werden erst bei dem nächsten großen Release des Systems mitgegeben.
Also zum Beispiel Ubuntu hat alle zwei Jahre ein sehr, sehr großes neues System.
Und inzwischen nur ein kleineres Release sozusagen.
Aber alle zwei Jahre gibt es wirklich ein fettes Release.
Wobei das bei Ubuntu eigentlich gar nicht so wirklich, nicht so hundertprozentig stimmt, meiner Ansicht nach.
Weil die versuchen eigentlich gerade in den LTS Releases nichts großartig Neues rein zu machen,
weil sie das die nächsten vier Jahre supporten müssen.
Also die LTS Releases sind meistens nur das, was die letzten ein, zwei Releases gemacht haben.
Ein bisschen und ein bisschen neuere Updates.
Also in LTS Releases machen die meistens keine großartigen Experimente.
Sozusagen alles dabei.
Und da sind dann eben auch die großen neuen Updates dabei.
Was natürlich für mich bedeutet, ich muss dann auch da quasi mein System fast neu installieren.
Wobei ich manche Sachen natürlich übernehmen kann.
Aber bei Arch gibt es das nicht.
Man hat einfach Arch Linux.
Man hat nicht irgendwie Arch Linux 12 oder 13 oder sowas.
Das gibt es einfach nicht.
Man hat einfach Arch.
Und die Software auf Arch installiert sich einfach nach und nach selbst.
Und ja, ich weiß, manche sprechen das Arch aus.
Manche sprechen das Arch aus.
Es heißt Arch.
Aber ich sage hier Arch.
Ich glaube es heißt, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass es offiziell tatsächlich Arch heißt.
Dazu, weil, ist so.
Die Ruhe fällt.
Okay, das ist so quasi das grobe, was man hier wissen muss.
Jetzt ist die Frage, möchte man das?
Also im Endeffekt Rolling Release kann dazu führen, dass das System kaputt geht.
Rolling Release auf dem Desktop ist das Beste.
Wenn man Sachen macht drauf.
Also wenn man Sachen programmiert oder halt neue Software-Versionen haben will.
Ich hatte früher halt auch so diese ganze Geschichte von wegen Ubuntu und sonst was.
Auf dem Server ist das eine gute Geschichte.
Da willst du kein Rolling Release.
Aber auf dem Desktop bin ich mittlerweile der Ansicht Rolling Release Beste.
Ich habe schon von vielen gehört, die sagen.
Rolling Release auf KaiSense.
Rolling Release auf keinen Fall in einer Umgebung, die wirklich funktionieren muss.
Also wenn man drauf angewiesen ist.
Weil eben was kaputt gehen könnte.
Ich persönlich nutze trotzdem Arch Linux, weil ja, ist halt einfach meiner Meinung nach.
Auf dem Desktop ist ja auch nicht so wichtig.
Der kann ruhig kaputt gehen.
Da passiert ja nichts.
... der besten Systeme, weil ich es auch wirklich sehr gut customizen kann.
Es ist allerdings auch nicht ganz so einfach.
Fast gar nicht richtig.
Wobei wir zum letzten Punkt kommen.
Welche Systeme würde ich vielleicht am ehesten empfehlen?
Für Anfänger würde ich, wie schon gesagt, meistens Linux Mint oder Manjaro empfehlen.
Ich empfehle Anfängern auch immer Linux Mint.
Themen kann man eigentlich alles machen.
Hier kommt es nur drauf an, möchte man jetzt ein Rolling Release haben oder möchte man das eigentlich nicht haben.
Für absolute Kack-Noobs Linux Mint.
Manjaro hat einen Rolling Release, Linux Mint hat keins.
Das ist wirklich Geschmackssache hier, was man da eigentlich verwenden möchte.
Dann gibt es natürlich noch sehr, sehr viele andere Systeme, die würde ich aber alle tatsächlich...
Also ich persönlich für mich.
Das ist jetzt nicht das, was ihr machen müsst.
Das ist nur mein persönlicher Geschmack jetzt hier gerade, okay?
Dieses Slide.
Und wenn euch jetzt, sagen wir mal, ein Kali Linux oder ein Ubuntu vielmehr fasziniert, dann nehmt das.
Absolut.
Das ist dann komplett eure Geschmackssache und die könnt ihr dann durchaus auch nehmen.
Für Anonymität würde ich immer ein Tails empfehlen.
Es geht nichts über Tails in den meisten, oder eigentlich nie, geht irgendwas da drüber.
Cubes ist ein super System, genauso wie Hunix.
Aber trotzdem, wenn ihr wirklich komplett anonym sein wollt, dann braucht ihr halt einfach ein Tails.
Ist so.
Und wenn ihr wirklich eine Herausforderung haben wollt, das heißt, wenn ihr wirklich euer Zuhause einrichten wollt auf eurem PC, dann kann ich euch wie gesagt...
Braucht man in Mint kein Terminal, Frau Crash Fluffy?
Naja, für die meisten Sachen nicht.
Aber man muss sich bei dem...
Wenn man wirklich mal Linux ausprobieren will, dann muss man sich mit dem Terminal einrichten.
Da muss man sich mit dem Terminal arrangieren.
Also, über kurz oder lang wird man die ein oder anderen Sachen im Terminal machen müssen.
Und man sollte, wenn man mit Linux anfängt, auch prinzipiell dazu bereit sein, was im Terminal zu machen und sich ein bisschen damit zu beschäftigen.
Weil viele Sachen unter Linux gehen nur im Terminal oder gehen am besten im Terminal.
Und es ist ja nicht so wie Windows, wo das Terminal abgrundtiefer Rotz ist.
Sondern das Terminal-Programm, als auch die Shell unter Linux, ist halt einfach viel, viel besser.
Als irgend so ein Windows-Terminal mit Batch.
Wobei das nicht ganz einfach ist.
Aber trotzdem eben noch so weit, dass man, wenn man es mal eingerichtet hat, wirklich sehr, sehr komfortabel alles machen kann.
Und das ist so mein Fazit hier dazu.
Ich bin gespannt, was ihr dazu schreibt.
Schreibt mir gerne, welche Systeme ihr benutzt.
Ja, finde ich ein gutes Video. Passt.
Deckt sich zu 90% mit meinen Erfahrungen, was ich auch sagen würde.
Aber man kann ja da auch unter unterschiedlicher Meinung sein.
Was macht ihr denn sonst noch für Videos?
Das waren jetzt wirklich kein schlechtes Video.
Oh, das ist cool, dass man mit solchen Videos tatsächlich 100.000 Abos kriegen kann.
Nicht übel.
Musst du erst mal hinkriegen.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht so das Thema, was jetzt die Leute, die KLS gucken, anspricht.
How we solved the worst minigame in Zelda history.
Ist ein bisschen lang gerade.
Ja gut, die Views sind nicht so hoch.
Auch durch sehr, sehr breit, was er hier macht.
Hier kommt irgendwas zum Passmodellen.
Dann kommt irgendwelche Algorithmus- und Datenstrukturen.
Hier kommt Linux-Distributionen-Vergleich.
Ist halt sehr breit.
Und da hast du halt klar, dass jetzt, sagen wir mal, Algorithmen und Datenstrukturen, irgendwelche Graphen,
dass das nicht so viele interessiert, wie zum Beispiel Linux-Vergleich.
Du könntest mein Gameplay-Video zu meinem neuen Spiel anschauen.
Klar.
Hau rein.
Schick her.
Ich glaube, dass das ein bisschen so eine Nische ist, wo es in Deutschland nicht viele gute Channels gibt in der Richtung.
Und die Videos, die wir bisher von ihm gesehen haben, sind auch wirklich kein Blödsinn.
Also da kannst du dich nicht beschweren.
Python-Tutorials, okay.
Strings.
Unreal Engine.
JavaScript.
Qt-GUI.
Benutzt du verschiedene VMs?
Ja.
Warum?
Was willst du wissen?
Linux für Upload-Einsteiger.
Könnte eigentlich auch mal ein Video machen.
Zum Thema Linux-Umstieg-Einstieg.
Ich habe es ja schon immer mal ein paar Mal angesprochen in ein paar Videos, aber ich habe nie ein eigenes Video zugemacht.
Er hat auch auf die Hacker-Doku reagiert.
Ich glaube, das haben wir uns schon zusammen angeguckt, ne?
Okay.
Moment.
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir jetzt.
Okay.
Der Trailer zum neuen Spiel von Luku.
Aus dem Chat.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken.
Okay.
Auf geht's.
Bits Battle.
Huge Voice-Effekt.
Was sehe ich da?
Es sind zwei Quadrate, die sich...
Das ist so ein bisschen was wie Worms.
Worms in Echtzeit oder sowas, ne?
Du solltest das umben...
Ist das ernsthaft?
Announcement?
Ähm...
Du solltest das umbenennen in Bit Battle Royal.
Nenn's oben in Bit Battle Royal und mach's auf Steam...
Ah ne, Greenlight gibt's ja nicht mehr.
Ähm...
Bit Battle Royal und dann auf Steam Early Access.
Excellent.
Ist auf Steam, okay.
Nice.
Early Access mit Steam Multiplayer.
Genau so muss man's machen.
Ähm...
Was wollen wir jetzt noch angucken?
Okay.
Also wir können uns den neuen Half-Life...
Den neuen Half-Life...
Den neuen Half-Life 1 Weltrekord Any% Speedrun angucken.
Der geht 25 Minuten ungefähr.
Alternativ hat man noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Das ist glaube ich nicht so interessant.
Was interessiert mich in Raspberry Pi OS mit Windows 10 Look ist eigentlich ziemlich...
Ne, wir gucken uns die schwersten Super Nintendo Spiele an.
Bisschen Retro Zeug für mich.
Ich brauch mal ein bisschen Oldschool Zeug.
Muss man uns angucken jetzt.
Wonka Old.
Wup Wup Old.
Leute.
Wir haben so viele Subs im Chat.
Wir müssen, wir brauchen einmal eine Runde Wup Old Spam.
Wup Old.
Gut.
Dann gucken wir das jetzt.
Ey, die waren auch schwer.
Ich muss aber sagen.
Ich war damals auch hochgradig unfähig.
Deswegen kamen mir viele Spiele so schwer vor.
Ich hab jetzt ja die, äh,
Command & Red Alert Kampagne gespielt gestern.
Ich hab jetzt ja die, äh, Command & Red Alert Kampagne gespielt gestern.
Und ich hab mich so schwer getan bei ursprünglichen, also bei den Levels im Original.
Weil das mein erstes Echtzeitstrategiespiel war.
Und jetzt war das easy as fuck.
Jetzt war das total easy zum größten Teil.
Nur damals.
Ja, nicht ganz, nicht ganz.
The Hook abonniert. Acht Monate. Exzellent.
Dankeschön.
Luko, kein Problem.
Wenn es ein neues Update gibt, sag Bescheid.
Oh, das war schwer.
Das ist das dritte Donkey Kong Country.
Das war wirklich schwer.
Ventress ist am Start.
Huge Spitz. Dankeschön. Ja, kein Problem.
Ja, kein Problem.
Konnte ich mal wenigstens jemand raiden,
der es gebrauchen kann.
Donkey Kong Country.
Generell fand ich die Donkey Kong Country Spiele
auf dem Super Nintendo ziemlich schwer.
Aber das Dreier war echt heftig.
Oh, I dislike uneven numbers.
I'm sure there's a ton of games out there that I wouldn't...
Ja, und diese ganzen Shooter, diese ganzen,
wie nennt sich der, diese Kategorien auch mal so
Shoot'em up mäßig, die waren auch
unsinnig schwer.
...be mentioning that I am no doubt deliberately
leaving off this...
Die Star Wars Games, die haben mir
sogar richtig gut gefallen auf dem Super Nintendo.
...just to make you mad.
Habe ich sogar,
habe ich sogar fast alle durchgespielt damals.
Oh Gott, Battletoads.
Warum kenne ich, warum kenne ich fast jedes Game
beim ersten Bild schon?
MonkaS Battletoads.
Das ist auch unsinnig schwer.
...seriousness.
If there's a game you think that deserves to be on here,
leave a comment below and explain why.
One other thing, no broken unplayable...
Castlevania, das ging...
Oh Gott, Contra 3. War das Contra 3?
Ich glaube es ist Contra 3.
Weil der Land auch wieder zensiert war.
...and beatable.
And yeah, I'm actually gonna do the internet clickbait thing
by doing an actual list.
Thirteen.
Donkey Kong Country 3.
All I gotta do is mention one level
lightning lookout.
There are pseudo-random lightning strikes
that are practically instantaneous
and almost impossible to dodge.
And if you're in the water when the lightning strikes,
you're dead.
Ich erinnere mich dunkel, ich erinnere mich dunkel.
Ich hatte das Game nicht.
Aber ein Kollege von mir
aus der Schule hatte das.
Ich hatte den dritten Teil nicht.
Was sind das für Einspieler
dazwischen?
Castlevania,
die waren allesamt ziemlich schwer,
die ersten paar.
Ich find immer geil,
wie die Amis Richter aussprechen.
Richter, der Richter.
Hatte ich nicht.
Die ganzen Castlevania-Spiele,
die ersten waren echt schwierig.
Anyway, the Super Nintendo version
may not be the best port,
but if you're looking for a challenge,
Dracula X delivers in spades.
Eleven.
Gradius III.
Mark...
L-D-M-N?
Drei Monate.
Dankeschön, excellent subscription.
Huge.
Und jetzt kommt der Scam-Train, Leute.
Der Scam-Train ist am Start.
Auf geht's.
Der Scam-Train fährt.
Oh, das,
ja, diese Dinger waren
ultraschwierig.
Gradius III.
Okay, das meine ich gar nicht,
aber es gab noch mehr solcher Spiele,
die waren allesamt brutalschwer.
I could very easily do that,
and nobody would blame me.
So many of these games are so tough.
But Gradius III in particular has a couple sections
that make you just want to tear your hair out.
You have to keep accelerating,
and you have to keep dodging to avoid instant death.
No power-ups can help you here,
except pure speed and quick reflexes.
The biggest problem here, though,
is that if you die, you start with nothing.
You're some sorry slow-ass ship again.
So you have no chance to get past this part.
You might as well just start over.
It's usually beneficial to have checkpoints,
but in this case it almost works against the game.
The two token power-ups you get
just barely give you enough speed to get past this part.
And that's if you're lucky.
Turn.
My first Earthworm Jim wasn't hard enough.
Lieblings-Corona-emote.
Nee, mein Lieblings-Corona-emote
is this one.
Corona.
Beste.
Hat mir nie gefallen.
Earthworm Jim
waren nie Games, die mir gefallen haben.
Weiß auch nicht. Das war nicht meins.
Wahrscheinlich, weil's zu abgedrehte Grafikstyle hatte.
Here you are flying around as a blind salamander
navigating your way through an intestinal tract.
And it's hard.
Your typical platforming stuff is here as well,
even more insane than its predecessor.
And yeah, there's quite a few checkpoints at least,
but I actually think this game's insane
and surreal nature makes Earthworm Jim 2
even harder, if that makes any sense.
And if it doesn't, then well,
you'll just have to play this and find out.
Nein.
Disney's The Lion King.
Hey, wait a second, what's a Disney game do-
Nicht. Nie gespielt.
Viele Disney-Spiele waren auch echt
Pain's Champ auf dem Super Nintendo.
...doing on this list. Well, anyone who
grew up playing Lion King is nodding their head
right now. There are certain areas in this game
that will make you tear your hair out.
Der hat nur eine Idle-Animation, oder?
...swinging across here. You have to be
absurdly precise. Down to the pixel
or you'll fall and you'll die.
Sieht sehr fair aus.
These damn monkeys.
Yeah, this game looks happy and bouncy
and all Disney and whatever, but certain jumps
and enemy patterns are infuriating.
Contra 3 The Alien Wars.
You know all about Contra, so I don't have to go into too much
detail here. The normal difficulty setting-
Aber richtig geiles Game gewesen.
Aber echt saumäßig schwierig.
Ich glaub, das hab ich nicht mal ansatzweise
durchgespielt. ...isn't that bad.
But to get to the game's true ending, you gotta beat the game
on hard. And man, there's so much stuff
flying all over the place, right from the get-go.
I mean, this is seriously within
the first 15 seconds of the first level.
Longtime viewers will remember
when I tried playing this drunk and I died three times
within a minute. Ihr seht hier beste 4 zu 3 Format.
Excellent. ...minute. Not my finest
moment among many poor moments.
But yeah, you wanna challenge? Crank through Contra 3
three times on all three difficulty
levels, and if you beat it on hard, you are
legit.
Ne. Battletoads and Battlemaniacs.
Battletoads ist
unnützschwer, auch die NES-Variante.
...only beat them up on this list, but hey, you gotta
have Battletoads featured in a video like this.
It just wouldn't be right otherwise. Anyway, this
is almost the exact same kind of difficulty
you'd expect from this franchise, with two
continues, no passwords, and that's it.
And of course, there's the Turbo Tunnel.
Just brutal. And the snake level that demands
perfect placement with your jumping.
And this part where you avoid the spikes?
Yeah, this is Battletoads. Ich fand die Spiele nicht mal gut,
die waren einfach nur schwer und sonst nix.
Six.
Actraiser 2. Kind of a disappointing
game, but maybe if you want a challenge?
This is one of the hardest side-scrollers you'll
ever play. Ja, RTX-Spiegelung, guckt
hier. RTX on.
...get hypnotized by how gorgeous Actraiser 2
looks, because all sorts of enemies and all
shapes and sizes come at you non-stop
from every direction and any direction.
At any time. Some patterns here
just aren't consistent or even discernible.
König der Löwen war auch schwer auf dem NES.
Hat er ja auch grad erzählt.
Viele der Disney-Games waren
unsinnig schwer und hatten ein sehr merkwürdiges
Movement. ...this game really frustrating.
No, there's no simulation or city... Kennt ihr mal noch dieses
komische Schlümpfe-Game auf dem Super Nintendo?
Das war auch komplett für'n Arsch.
Das war...
...Steuerung auf
Doom. ...building here like the first
Actraiser is just side-scrolling action and
flailing away and hoping you get a little bit
further on this life than you did the last
time you died in embarrassingly quick fashion.
...five.
...super R-Type. Here again
Okay, ja, das war schwer. ...we have a classic horizontal shoot-'em-up
experience. Die und lose all your weapons.
But unlike Gradius III, there's no
checkpoints anywhere. You have to start
all the way back at the beginning. Der braucht schon
Checkpoints. And the hardest thing about losing everything is losing your
speed, especially if you're further into the
game. Everything is so much faster than you
that you're better off just starting over.
So yeah, the same problems as Gradius III,
but in this instance, you start at the beginning of
every long ass level. That is
ridiculous, but that leads me to...
...four. R-Type III.
This is a much better game than
Super R-Type, because there are actual
checkpoints here, but the enemy design
and the level layouts make the difficulty more
organic and fast. Oder habe ich das gespielt und das andere nicht?
Ach, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau.
Das war nie so meine Art
von Spielen. Das war für zwischendurch ganz gut.
Eins meiner Lieblingsspiele auf dem Super Nintendo,
neben den offensichtlichen Sachen wie
A Link to the Past, Mario World und so, war das
erste Mega Man X. Das habe ich
gerne gespielt damals. Und ich fand's
auch voll schwer, obwohl es gar nicht so schwer war.
Da kommen einfach noch Gegner reingeflogen.
Drei. Super Ghouls and Ghosts.
Oh ja, das war auch
ultra frustrierend.
The difficulty in this game is kind of
two-fold. First, you have to understand that
there's a particular way to play this game.
If you try and play it like a run-and-gun game...
Das war ein richtiges Stelz-Game im Endeffekt. Du musstest
immer zwei Pixel vorgehen und in die
Richtung der Gegner spammen, dann
gucken, ob was passiert, dann wieder...
Also...
Eigentlich hat's mir auch nicht gefallen.
...platformer like Mario, then you'll
probably consider this game to be broken and
you won't even get to the first checkpoint
of the first level. Super Ghouls and Ghosts
is a puzzle-platformer that takes a lot of patience,
a watchful eye, and a knack for good timing.
So once you get over that hump, then you can
get to the game's real difficulty, so be
prepared to die again...
Ich glaub, man musste das mehrfach sogar durchspielen.
...again and again, but this game
is beatable, I swear. Stuff like
this sequence here, it takes a long
time to memorize. Ich mein, die Steuerung
allein schon. Generell hat...
Es hatten viele Super Nintendo-Spiele
echt Kack-Steuerung.
...all the crap flying at you,
good lord. This game is doable,
really, it is, but man, it is
unforgiving.
...true.
The Super Star Wars games...
Ja, die fand ich auch cool. Die fand ich nice.
...including all three here, because
they're all insane.
I don't understand why these games bother labeling
their difficulty levels, because even on
easy, the Super Star Wars games are...
Kann mich da noch dran erinnern? Die fand ich gar nicht
so schwer, also...
...ähm...
Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher, welche... Ich glaub, ich weiß...
Ich glaub, ich hab sie alle gespielt, aber ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Kann auch sein, dass es nicht alle waren.
Die Spiele hatten
Heldenauswahl. Man konnte am Anfang der Levels teilweise
die Helden auswählen, und in der Regel
waren die Helden, die schießen konnten, viel besser
als die Helden, die nahe an die Gegner
ran mussten.
All these games are even more frustrating, because
you do see that you eventually get to play as
Chewbacca and Han Solo, and I just
wanna get even that far. What's funny
is that even with cheat codes like
Da gab's so ein Mode 7 Level,
wo du mit dem Raumschiff rumgeflogen bist und
eigentlich kaum was erkannt hast.
...unlimited health, these games are still
frickin' impossible. If I had to pick one,
the hardest of the three is probably Empire Strikes Back.
Vielleicht hab ich das nicht gespielt, sondern
die einfacheren. The Darth Vader battle
is just laughable. I mean, what am I
supposed to do here?
Ich glaub, das hab ich nicht gespielt.
...and the number one toughest Super Nintendo game?
Hagane. Hab ich nicht gespielt.
Keine Ahnung. War das nicht
das, was gar nicht...
War das nicht eines der letzten Games, die für den
Super Nintendo überhaupt erschienen sind? Da war doch
irgendwas, hm? Ich erinnere mich dunkel.
Wahrscheinlich kam's auch gar nicht
in Deutschland raus.
...and you're gonna need every single one, because
this game is relentless. It does not stop.
It will haunt your dreams. It is fast
as hell, and it takes every ounce of
concentration to keep up. Hagane is
totally worth it, though. There's some remarkably
clever level design, and I love this level
where you're getting chased by the flames.
But yeah, as you can see, it is hard
as balls from this first segment of the
first level onward. The thing is, though, this game
is so well made, that I think it's absolutely
worth the challenge. Hagane is one of
those games you just have to play for yourself.
It's all about feel, and if it agrees
with you, then you'll find the challenge pretty
appealing. And again, I can't overstate how
awesome it is to have so many different
attacks, but what makes Hagane stand out is
that usually when your character is this
overpowered, you're able to just bulldoze your
way through the game, like, say, Skyblazer
or Sparkster or something like that. But in
Hagane, the enemies and level design match
your abilities. It's fun, it's smooth, it's intuitive,
and it's just on the edge of being so hard
that it's unfair, but it doesn't quite
cross over. That's what makes Hagane the
hardest game on the Super Nintendo.
Alright, that's all for now. Thanks for watching,
and have a great rest of your day.
Excellent.
Okay, Leute, ähm,
wollten wir uns jetzt den aktuellen Half-Life
1 Weltrekord noch angucken?
Auf was hatten wir uns geeinigt?
Chat? Ey, von
dem Typ haben wir doch schon mal was geguckt, oder?
Der kommt mir irgendwie bekannt
vor.
Ich glaub, das letzte... 27 Minuten.
WTF, he's playing another game while
speedrunning. Okay, nice.
Okay.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
I haven't played Star Wars in a while now.
What? Der spielt wirklich
irgendwie Star Wars oder sonst was noch nebenbei?
WTF? Ich will nicht
wissen, wie viele Milliarden Stunden der wieder in dem
Game hat. Wartet mal ganz kurz.
Der hat alle Stunden, da sind keine mehr übrig.
Ich find's immer geil,
wenn die dann irgendwie sagen, hello Gordon,
und der Typ schon irgendwie 3 Kilometer weiter.
It's good to see you,
Gordon. Ja, ich bin schon 20 Kilometer
weiter gesprungen.
Oh, wie's ruggelt.
Oh, das ist
teilweise so precise, wie du da das Zeug
springen musst.
Huge, huge animations von 1998.
See, he knows, he
continued moving, he didn't stop.
Die Mauser.
So, that's something by lowering FPS.
Man konnte doch die
NPCs irgendwie schieben, hä?
What?
Der spielt wirklich ein anderes Game während der Half-Life
speedrun. WTF?
No challenge, no challenge.
Ist das Jedi Knight, oder
was ist das?
Das ist
weird flex.
Weird flex.
Das ist
dual speedrun.
Ich wollt auch grad sagen, Rico, neues
Meta. Man speedrunnt
einfach zwei Spiele gleichzeitig.
Und nebenbei Weltrekord
in einem machen. Eigentlich ist das richtig
big brain. Warum sollte man nur ein
Weltrekord machen, wenn man zwei Weltrekorde
gleichzeitig machen kann?
Eigentlich ist das richtig next level.
Einfach double world record.
You can use
mouse wheel
to turn 90 degrees.
It's helpful sometimes.
Die übertreiben's,
die Leute.
Gerade rechtzeitig da, um den
Kopf zu spammen.
Exakt dieser Pixel muss es sein.
Ich find's
so geil, wie er ein zweites Game nebenbei
spielt.
Wenn speedrun von einem Game zu langweilig
wird.
Winklino ist echt so.
Stellt euch vor, ihr habt den Half-Life
1 World Record. Ihr habt jahrelang
geübt für das Spiel. Und dann kommt er
daher
und spielt zwei Spiele nebenbei.
Und easy as fuck World Record.
Okay, man muss fernes halber sagen,
es ist jetzt nicht ganz so extrem, wie es aussieht.
In dieser Zeit, er muss ja in Half-Life
nichts machen. Er muss einfach nur das Timing
abpassen, wann er wieder ins Game muss.
Aber trotzdem geil.
Als nächstes kommt wahrscheinlich noch
ein Minecraft Survival Speedrun dabei
als drittes Game. Weil da musst du
noch weniger machen.
Aber ich habe den Rebound
für den Attack gehalten.
Okay, wir sparen hier.
Äh,
okay.
7 Sekunden.
Das ist ein 7 Sekunden
Cycle, den wir jetzt machen.
Okay, das war falsch.
So, weiter geht's.
Half-Life Speedrun.
Ja, der schaut gerade im anderen Game,
wie er 7 Sekunden schneller sein kann, während er
in Half-Life World Record macht.
Das ist seriös.
Wow.
Man kann da raus?
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass das geht.
Das...
Das ist was Neues, oder?
Leute, ich bilde mir ein, im letzten
Half-Life Speedrun, wo wir geguckt haben, war das
noch nicht drinne.
Das ist, glaube ich, was Neues.
Was heißt, in diesem Universum ist eigentlich
die Katastrophe in Black Mesa nie passiert.
Weil Gordon hat nie das Sample
in den Strahl geschoben.
Das ist neu, ne? Real-Verse-Player-EU.
Habe ich so auch noch nicht gesehen.
Der überspringt quasi
den ganzen Weg von diesem Reaktorraum
bis hier oben hin.
Ja.
Ich glaube, der hat auch... Ne, das Brecheisen hat er
nicht übersprungen. Das Brecheisen ist hier erst.
How do you attack
after grabbing the crowbar?
I press mouse 1 repeatedly.
I think I click like twice and then hold it
after on the third click, I guess.
I think that's right.
Excellent crowbar strats.
I guess as long as you hold it...
Aber das Movement ist extrem flüssig, ne?
Das Movement ist so krass
flüssig, der bleibt nirgendswo dran hängen
und hat permanent Bunnyhop-Speed.
Hier unten siehst du ja den Speed.
Das ist so flüssig, wie der sich bewegt.
...and it knocks glitching out somehow.
Half-Life ist
eigentlich ein relativ langes Game.
Also so
First-Person-Shooter-mäßig
ist Half-Life, würde ich mal behaupten,
eines der längsten Singleplayer-Kampagnen.
Kannst du ne ganze
Weile spielen.
Oder halt in 25 Minuten durchspielen.
Der hat jetzt einfach grad mal das...
Der hat einfach mal
komplett das Level geskippt gerade.
WTF?
The fuck? Der hat... Der ist durch die
erste Hel... Naja, nicht durch die erste... Durch die erste
Drittel vom Spiel ist er gleich durch.
Ha!
Genau, ich frag dich... Und was hast du in der Mittagspause
gemacht? Ah, ich hab zweimal Half-Life durchgespielt.
Warum wackelt er die ganze Zeit mit
der Kamera? Baut er dadurch Speed auf? Ja.
Die... Diese Bunnyhop-Speed-Geschichte
geht nur, wenn du...
ähm... wenn... wenn die
Kamera... wenn die Kamera movt.
Ja, es gibt dazu ein richtig schönes Tutorial-Video.
Also, dass diese Bunnyhop-Speed-Geschichte,
dass du den Speed halten kannst, musst du...
...in nem gewissen
Winkel zur Wand gucken oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich krieg's nicht mehr zusammen, aber das ist...
...gehört dazu, dass du schneller laufen kannst.
Letztendlich geht das Ganze
übrigens auch nur, weil das Quake-Engine ist.
Ja. Das... Das ist das Bunnyhopping...
...das Bunnyhopping in der Quake-Engine.
I think he would have run all the way there.
Das erste Drittel vom Game
ist fertig. Nach... nach... vier Minuten.
Xsssssssssssss
Da kann man übrigens
gar nicht reinkloppen normalerweise.
Kann man erst rein, nachdem er hier einmal durch ist.
Krass.
The fuck, Alter?
Jesus.
I have, like, the...
...the worst amount of speed on the...
Jetzt boostet er sich...
Der ist auf der Leiter
gelandet, da unten. Habt ihr's gesehen? Er ist auf der Leiter
gelandet, dass er kein Damage nimmt.
Jetzt gibt's nochmal einen Granaten-Boost.
...that I am in the...
Das Game ist, glaube ich,
relativ schwierig, bis zum letzten...
...bis so das letzte Viertel anbricht.
Dann hat man nahezu unendlich Leben.
Aber bis dahin ist es
ziemlich, ziemlich durchoptimiert.
I am in there as long as possible,
very much, pretty much.
I don't hit the ceiling or anything.
Ich find's eigentlich cool, dass es diesen... diesen
Unlimited-Leben-Clitch erst so im letzten Viertel gibt.
Das heißt, bis dahin muss man das Game
noch richtig spielen.
Okay, richtig spielen ist jetzt übertrieben gesagt.
Also, durchwetzen.
Aber...
Ey, die... das Movement ist so
flüssig, ey.
Da steckt viel Übung dahinter.
Ich hab gedacht, er wechselt jetzt aufs andere
Spiel rüber, während er Aufzug fährt.
Das wär's jetzt gewesen.
Das hätt ich damals auch gerne gemacht.
Weil immer dieses Rumgerennen
durch diesen Tentakel-Raum...
Der sieht total entspannt aus. Ja,
das ist easy mode für ihn. Wahrscheinlich
hat er auch 4000 Stunden oder so schon in Half-Life.
Bull-Squid alive
is sketch.
Was gibt denn das jetzt?
Ah, dass er da drüber kommt.
Alles klar.
Excellent.
Ui!
Und ins Wasser, dass er kein Damage nimmt.
I don't know anything about Black Mesa, so I cannot say.
It looks...
Aber das Movement ist so übertrieben flüssig,
obwohl du in Half-Life an jeder Ecke hängenbleiben kannst.
It could be fun to...
Learn it
basically.
Basic speedrun
fashion. Der hat Glück, dass ihn die Headcrab nicht
killt.
Übrigens, der hat doch nicht... Ich hab vergessen,
dass er die Xen-Levels noch spielen muss.
Also der ist doch noch nicht ein Drittel
durch gewesen am Anfang, wo ich's gesagt hab.
Jetzt ist er ungefähr ein Drittel durch.
Also das erste Drittel ist quasi ungefähr
bis die Soldaten auftauchen, dann
das zweite Drittel ist bis man in die Alien-Welt kommt
und das letzte Drittel ist quasi die Alien-Welt.
One level at a time.
I complete
the one level
in Half-Life.
Then I
tap into Black Mesa and I complete the same level
and then I repeat it.
Der ist schneller als die NPCs
spawnen hier richtig.
Yes, speed is very nice
this run. Very nice
run. What did I get for bottom push?
Should be
faster than what I've gotten before.
That's my best ever.
Wie einfach mal
den Boss gemacht hat. Easy as fuck
nebenbei.
Oh. Man kann doppelt
aufladen.
Good speed.
Not sub 10 though.
What?
What? What the fuck?
Was war das?
Okay, that was a decent grab.
Good speed.
Not sub 10 though.
What is happening?
Was passiert?
Oh, finally.
Okay, alles klar.
Rail, er klitscht sich drüber.
Den Klitsch
mehr oder weniger,
den kannte ich damals auch schon 1998.
Ich hab das damals so gemacht, ich hab mich mit
diesen Minen, die man an die Wand hängen kann.
Kennt ihr noch diese Minen mit dem blauen Laserstrahl,
die man an die Wand hängen kann in Half-Life?
Da haben wir uns auch über die Wand drüber geklitscht,
dass wir das Level nicht spielen mussten.
Also quasi
auch schon Speedrun-Strats.
Ich glaube, das ist das Beste, was ich jemals gemacht habe.
Und on Rail
haben wir auch oft gespielt, ohne Rail.
Warte, ist das es? Nein, was?
Die Dinger da meine ich.
Okay.
Das ist mir so nicht bewusst,
dass das wirklich ist.
Normalerweise sollst
du hier ja mit so einer
Minibahn rumfahren.
Okay.
Das ist sketchy, aber
das Moven ist so.
Wir haben nicht so viel Schaden, wir sind in Ordnung.
Das ist so exakt von ihm.
Jetzt kommt die Rakete.
Heftig.
Also bis dahin spielst du normalerweise so
sechs Stunden oder so.
Sechs, sieben Stunden.
Acht HP,
ja, da darf nicht auf die Kleise kommen.
Nee.
Good Pace.
Ich würde das alles nach Good Pace aussehen.
These Mistakes, dude.
Oh, Reload, MonkaS.
We're in there again.
Acht HP und 14 Shield.
But we're in it now.
We're back, Kappa.
Kappa.
Er safet ja auch alle paar Meter.
Ich glaube, das hat zwei Gründe. Erstens, dass er sich natürlich nicht so weit
resetet wird, wenn er stirbt.
Und zweitens schaltet Saven
irgendwelche Sachen aus.
Ich glaube, manche Sachen spawnen nicht,
es gibt keine Hit Detection und
manche Sachen lösen nicht aus, weil man
safet im richtigen Moment.
Wenn er im falschen Moment safet, ist auch RIP.
Ja, dann ist es vorbei.
Das haben sie
in Black Mesa übrigens rausgenommen,
diesen Part hier.
Einfach mal durch die Wand kurz
aufladen.
Das Game möchte übrigens nicht,
dass du hier draußen bist, weil Neba dir gerade
eine Rakete startet. In dem Game stehst du hinterm Fenster,
im Raum und kannst normalerweise nicht raus.
Den Portal Speedrun,
ja klar.
Pater, oh herrli.
Vier Monate, dankeschön. Excellent Subscription.
Big Brain.
Warum muss man
eigentlich storytechnisch die Rakete hochjagen?
Wegen irgendeinem Satellit.
Ich hab's nie richtig gecheckt.
Ist die Half-Life 1 Speedrun Community
groß?
Ich weiß nicht, man könnte einfach mal gucken,
wie aktiv neue Runs submitted werden.
Genau, das ist der Satellit.
Das ist das Portal zu schließen. Irgendwie sowas.
Half-Life Lore.
Oh, er ist gestorben.
Und jetzt kommt die Szene,
die werden wir jetzt wahrscheinlich gar nicht sehen,
wo ich als Kind übelst
Schiss vor hatte.
Wenn der Fisch aus dem Wasser kommt.
Hast du Alyx gespielt?
Nee, noch nicht.
Ich hadere noch mit mir, eine 3D-Brille zu kaufen.
Eine VR-Brille für ein Spiel.
Hier, da hatte ich übelst Schiss vor,
wo ich klein war.
Vor dem Fisch, der aus diesem trüben Wasser kommt.
Aber man kann ihn auch einfach skippen. Easy.
WTF.
Das ist normalerweise unter Strom,
da kann man nicht durch.
Easy.
So.
Halbzeit.
Das Game ist ungefähr zur Hälfte rum jetzt.
What?
Ach!
Man muss die gar nicht killen!
Ich dachte immer, man muss diese
Assassin-Typen killen, dass es weitergeht.
Was hältst du von Valorant?
Ich habe es selbst nicht gespielt,
ich kenne es nur aus Streams.
Ich finde gut, dass es mehr CS ist als Overwatch.
Guck es gerne an.
Das wird mitgerechnet, das Save & Load.
Wir machen es sehr, sehr gut.
Ja.
Sehr gut.
26.
Aber, der ist auch echt krass in dem Game.
Aber wenn man sich das Movement anguckt,
wie flüssig der das hinkriegt, ist Wahnsinn.
Das war der schnellste, den ich je gespielt habe.
31 vielleicht? 36 letzte Runde.
Was ich in der Half-Life-Story
ja nie so richtig kapiert habe ist,
warum bringen sie Gordon Freeman
an der Stelle nicht einfach um
und werfen ihn lieber in eine Schrottpresse?
Das ist so low-brain
von den Gegnern.
Weißt du,
du hast einen, der 100 Leute
von dir gekillt hat,
du nimmst ihn gefangen
und anstatt ihn einfach zu killen,
wirfst du ihn in eine Schrottpresse
und lässt ihn unbeaufsichtigt in einer Schrottpresse liegen.
Exzellent, genau so.
Genau so muss man es machen.
Man kann die Schrottpresse fahren,
weil, das sieht das Spiel
eigentlich nicht vor, die Schrottpresse,
ist im Spiel eine Bahn.
Der ist echt gut.
Aber gut, er hat nicht umsonst den Weltrekord.
Oh, er ist gestorben.
MonkaS.
Wow.
What the fuck?
Alter, was? Was geht jetzt ab?
What?
Okay, alles klar.
Ja, alles klar.
Alles klar.
Ich blick voll durch, was passiert gerade.
Was passiert überhaupt?
Ja, ist schon klar, dass es ein Damage Boost ist,
aber wie flüssig er das macht, ist Wahnsinn.
What?
Das geht?
Okay, alles klar.
Guck, wenn man jetzt speichert,
lösen die Minen nicht aus.
Ah, ja.
Die Gegner müssen sich auch nur denken,
war da was?
Der ist bestimmt guter CS-Surfer.
Ja, glaub ich auch.
Ah, ja, alles klar.
Oh, das war nervig, wenn du die Wissenschaftler hier retten musst.
Moment.
Man konnte Sorum doch gar nicht durch.
Warum konnte der Sorum durch?
Easy.
Off, mach hin.
NPC, go, go.
Hatte die jetzt absichtlich nicht getroffen?
Ich hab immer auf den Wissenschaftler gewartet,
dass der mit raus kann.
Keine Speedrun-Stats.
HP slow.
Woah!
Das rhymed.
Almost good.
Ah, exzellent.
Big Ghost use.
What am I doing?
Was hat er gerade gesagt?
Mom KS?
Shotgun reloaded, that's good.
Wir haben schon mal einen Half-Life-Speedrun geguckt,
aber ich hab das wieder voll verdrängt.
Alter, wie krass, guckt euch das mal an.
Reloaded, that's good.
Aber...
Wir haben ja Black Mesa im Stream mal gespielt.
Du bist normalerweise, will das Game von dir,
Prisa spielt Software-Rendering,
dass man hier runter geht, unten durch
und dann auf der anderen Seite wieder hoch
und den Heli bekämpft auf dem Zwischenweg.
Und er denkt sich so einfach, nee, machen wir nicht.
Wir fliegen einfach mal kurz mit dem,
was ist das, diese Gauss-Rifle-Dings,
Weapon, ich weiß nicht genau,
einfach mal kurz über die ganze Map,
schießen nochmal da hin, exakt da hin,
dass wir dann da rauskommen.
Easy. Und direkt im Rohr landen.
Das war easy, kann jeder, kann jeder.
Easy as fuck.
Okay, wir fliegen mal kurz über...
What?
Was?
Okay, alles klar.
Alles klar.
Wie du machst das anders.
Explosions.
Alles klar.
Okay.
So, gleich gibt es den,
demnächst kommt der Unlimited-Leben-Klitsch.
Würde man sagen, so zwei, drei, oder zwei Minuten
oder so.
Wie, den nicht treffen?
Okay, ein bisschen Glück gehört auch dabei.
Jetzt, jetzt kommt der Unlimited-Leben-Klitsch.
Also seht ihr,
es gibt die Möglichkeit, man kann sich hier einklemmen
in der Tür, und es geht
aber wohl irgendwie nur so an dieser Tür.
Und jetzt overflowt das Game total
die Lebensenergie. Guckt, seht ihr das hier unten?
Und jetzt hat man mehr oder weniger fast nahezu
unendlich Leben.
Jetzt kann er auch noch direkt Damage boosten, wie verrückt.
Warum sollte man das aufschießen?
Man kann das einfach von Hand machen.
Normalerweise soll man auf dieses Artillerie-Ding
und dann auf so einer Map einstellen,
wo das aufgeschossen wird, aber da macht er es einfach selbst.
Kein Problem, kein Problem.
Okay, so ungefähr zwei Drittel vom Game
Okay, so ungefähr zwei Drittel vom Game.
sind durch.
Aber wisst ihr, was ich an dem Speedrun cool finde?
Mehr oder weniger, es gibt
es gibt einiges, es gibt schon einiges,
aber dass er mehr oder weniger das Spiel
spielt.
Vom Ablauf her, wie es so sein muss.
Dass es kein komplettes Out of Bounds
Klitschen ist oder so, sondern dass das Spiel
einfach nur gespielt wird.
Und das sind eigentlich die besten Speedruns.
Und wo man auch wirklich sieht, der Typ kann es.
Der hat es halt richtig drauf.
Ich dachte immer, man muss den Panzer killen, dass es weiter geht.
Anscheinend nicht, anscheinend nicht.
Ja Skyrim Speedruns
sind unter anderem total lame.
Und auch
die normalen Doom Eternal Speedruns sind lame.
Aber die
Ultra Nightmare Speedruns sind cool.
Was?
Okay.
Nice.
Witcher 3 Speedrun habe ich
weiß ich nicht, ob ich da schon mal einen geguckt habe.
Hat der gerade durch die Wand irgendeinen
gelasert?
Jetzt switcht er erstmal auf das andere Game wieder gleich.
Ja, die Portal Speedruns
finde ich tatsächlich nicht so gut.
Die sind beim ersten Mal gucken cool, aber danach werden sie langweilig.
Wobei ich mir den Half-Life Speedrun durchaus
4-5 mal angucken kann.
Im Jahr ist kein Problem.
Gibt es dieses Jahr
GameStorm Quick?
Keine Ahnung, gucke ich auch nicht mehr in letzter Zeit.
Funktioniert das
alles auch bei Black Mesa? Nein.
Ein paar Sachen funktionieren noch.
Aber das ganze Movement ist anders.
Black Mesa hat eine neuere
Version von der Source Engine, also mal ganz davon
abgesehen, das hier ist ja noch nicht mal die Half-Life 2
Source Engine, das ist ja Gold Source, die Half-Life
1 Engine unten drunter.
Und bei den neueren Source Versionen funktioniert auch
das Movement ein bisschen anders, wie bei Release Versionen.
Ne, ne.
Ein paar Sachen funktionieren bestimmt noch, aber das meiste
kannst du in Black Mesa nicht machen.
Zumal Xen
komplett anders in Black Mesa ist.
Moment. Das geht?
Man muss den Fight nicht machen.
Das geht?
Moment.
Ich dachte, man muss den Fight machen, dass man
in den Teleporter springen kann.
Hier ist normalerweise quasi
so der End-Fight auf der Erde.
In dem Raum.
Das ist quasi so eine Art Boss-Fight hier.
Die gibt es gar nicht.
Ja, alles klar.
Na dann.
Nicht denken, wissen, Neo. Genau.
Thank God.
Oh Jesus, please.
Please be that.
Ah yes, excellent.
Don't lose time here.
It's on a cycle, so I got it, I believe.
Ist der Fight nicht bei Blue Shift?
Bei Blue Shift kommst du hier kurz vorbei,
ja? Und bei Blue Shift
darfst du nicht in das Portal hüpfen, weil dann stirbst
du. Weil Blue Shift musst du dann
irgendwo abbiegen zwischendurch.
Warum kenn ich eigentlich noch
die Half-Life Level auswendig?
Weil Boomer.
I was worried.
The fading felt so long in there.
Jesus.
Half-Life 1 ist mittlerweile älter als
die YouTube-Deutschland-Community.
True. 0 W.
Ja, ist so.
Half-Life 1 ist 22 Jahre alt.
Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Es rockelt ein bisschen.
Don't look at chat.
Das ist immer eine gute Idee, wenn man sich
konzentrieren will.
Yes, man.
I might not get sub 27 here, but
follow my Twitch.
Maximum 1337
on twitch.tv.
Okay.
Here we go. You got it, guys.
Und wie
slowt er das Game down?
Command. Ach, das ist erlaubt.
Okay, das hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
Genau. Das habe ich damals
auch schon rausgekriegt gehabt, als ich
gespielt habe, dass man den Boden hier
aufsprengen kann, ohne den
Gegner.
Okay. Das habe ich damals auch schon
rausgekriegt.
I forgot what the strat was.
Okay. Don't please know.
Okay, we got this.
I mean, this is literally free right now.
Was ein Move. Na gut, der ist ein bisschen
hängen geblieben, aber trotzdem. Immer noch
extrem gut. Jesus.
Okay, we're fine. I'm gonna take the
Gauss just in case.
Das ist Weltrekord, ja.
Ist übrigens gleich fertig.
Normalerweise bräuchte man jetzt noch
ungefähr eine Stunde. Okay, that's good.
Er macht es in einer Minute. Easy.
Oh my god, this is...
This is probably it, guys.
Nei!
I should stop talking.
Every time I say something like that, I fail.
Commentator's curse.
Wow!
Wooo!
Okay.
I got it. Oh my god.
Don't fail, Maxim.
Easy, easy bossfight
jetzt.
Lol.
Übrigens, eigentlich
muss man dem Gegner in den Kopf schießen, ne?
Aber anscheinend kann man eben auch in
Bobbles schießen, dass das ins Gehirn geht.
Also quasi
vom Hintern ins Gehirn, das ist...
Egal. Easy win.
What the fuck?
7 und 20, 13.
What is this time, dude?
Easy World Record. Nebenbei noch ein anderes
Game gespielt. Oh my god.
Heftig.
Echt heftig.
Also da sieht man richtigen
Skill in dem Game, ey.
GG
eats.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
What the fuck? Nicht so...
Nicht so laut.
Um wie viel hat er den Weltrekord
geschlagen? Guck mal mal. Speedrun, Half-Life.
Äh...
Ist das die richtige Kategorie?
Ist das die richtige
Kategorie hier?
Ja, ne, Max? Ja, das muss es sein.
Er hat den Speedrun geschlagen. Na gut, das war vor 9 Tagen.
Also den hier hat er geschlagen.
Ähm...
Oh, guckt mal hier.
Richtig. 7 und 20, 13.
40 Sekunden, so...
45 Sekunden schneller.
50, 50. 50 Sekunden, genau.
Äh...
50 Sekunden.
Das ist heftig, ey.
50 Sekunden schneller.
Das ist ja massive.
Da ist... Und da ist auch noch ein bisschen
Luft nach oben.
9 Tagen ärgert sich bestimmt, ja. Bestimmt.
Heftig.
Mon KS.
Ach, ja.
Leute, ich muss jetzt was essen.
Ich hab Hunger wie Sau.
Oh...
Die restlichen Videos heben wir uns fürs nächste Mal auf.
Vor allem das hier.
Danach Warzone. Ja.
Aber nicht im Stream.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal was essen. Ich hab Hunger.
Gibt's irgendjemand, den wir hosten
können, der on ist?
Ähm...
Der es gebrauchen könnte.
Äh...
Keine Mich-Folge.
Okay, Leute.
Sehr schön, dass wieder so viele dabei waren.
Beim Aufwachen.
Ähm...
Vielleicht sehen wir uns morgen wieder.
Oder heute Abend oder so. Man weiß ja nicht.
Mal gucken. Ich bin ja in letzter Zeit relativ...
Ich wollte euch noch was...
Ich wollte euch noch was fragen. Hab ich ganz vergessen.
Weil ich euch gestern schon noch fragen wollte.
Ähm...
Ich bin ja in letzter Zeit relativ
oft am Start.
Guckt mal. Wenn man jetzt hier bei mir mal schaut.
Auf Twitch.
Dann sieht man ja, wenn man auf Videos geht.
Nein, Max.
Ich will mich nicht selbst hören.
Wenn man auf Videos geht, sieht man ja,
dass...
Videos...
Da sieht man ja, ich bin relativ viel
on in letzter Zeit.
Drei Stunden, 21 Stunden, zwei Tage,
fünf Tage, sechs Tage, vor sechs Tagen,
vor sieben Tagen, vor acht Tagen.
Also ich bin ja gefühlt jeden zweiten oder dritten Tag on.
Äh...
Ich hab kein Sketchy online. Hab ich nicht.
Aber...
Ich wollte euch nämlich was fragen.
Es ist ja in letzter Zeit so, seitdem ich so oft streame,
dass...
ich nicht mehr in jedem Stream
vorher
ein...
habe, was ich genau machen will.
So, jetzt ist die Frage, was ist euch lieber?
Soll ich nur streamen, wenn ich mir vorher was
überlegt habe, was wir machen können?
Oder soll ich weiter streamen, wie jetzt, einfach, wenn es mir danach ist?
Weil jetzt würde ich mal sagen,
früher bin ich halt immer on gekommen,
wenn ich genau was Spezielles
vor hätte.
Und jetzt komme ich halt auch, sagen wir mal so,
die Hälfte der Zeit on, ohne dass ich
großartig was vorhabe.
Du entwickelst doch immer was Tolles draus. Das ist schön,
wenn das so funktioniert, ja.
Weiter wie jetzt.
Dann machen wir das weiter so.
Ich guck dir auch zu, wenn du
auf AliExpress komische Kabel kaufst.
Ja, das müssen wir übrigens
demnächst mal wieder machen.
Ich muss tatsächlich mal wieder AliExpress was bestellen.
Und meine AliExpress-Lieferung,
die wir vor zwei Monaten
oder so bestellt haben, ist immer noch nicht da.
Aber das liegt, glaube ich, an...
Corona.
Und wir können diesmal auch bei Banggood
was bestellen, ja. Bester Shop noch.
Bester Name. Banggood.
Okay, dann machen wir weiter so wie bisher.
Also, bis denn.
Bis morgen oder so. Mal schauen.
Macht's gut. Ich muss jetzt erst mal aufs Klon was essen.
Bis denn. See you.